This is Jocko podcast number
73 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
It has been quite a few
episodes since we did some Q.
And. A. You don't answered some
questions from the interwebs.
We had a series of guests hate a couple
books and just kind of slid a little bit
on Q. And. A. So Q. And A. Yeah,
let's rock.
Let's question number one.
Christian Moore. Yeah.
Well, Christian, the one Jocko,
do you have to make a conscious effort
not to overreact to situations or is it
natural slash ingrained now?
I would say at this point it's,
it's fairly ingrained and
I don't overreact to a lot
of stuff anymore. In fact,
sometimes I just don't react
to stuff to be honest with you.
When things are going on, I'll just
be sort of okay, Yup, nod the head,
you know,
listen to what's happening,
listen to the people freaking
out and I don't, yeah,
I don't overreact to
a lot of stuff that's,
I think it's pretty ingrained right now.
And I would say that in
order to get there, you know,
in order to s to try and move in that
direction because that is the best way to
be. Again, I'm not saying to be a robot,
I'm not saying you should have no emotions
and you should know never show any,
and I'm not saying that,
but you shouldn't.
You should have some
control over those emotions.
Especially from a leadership perspective.
Right.
That's what I'm talking about here
from a leadership perspective.
So one of the things that you can
do is when you, when you, when,
when chaos starts to hit,
you know, picture that,
what does this look like from the outside?
What do I look like from the outside?
When somebody says something,
Hugh,
that's traumatic or is going to cause a
disturbance or it's gonna cause problems
immediately think yourself,
okay,
what am I going to look like
from the outside right now?
What am I going to look like to them?
If they're recording this in your head,
like they're recording this and we're
going to go sit down and watch it later.
When they first came out
with in the seal teams,
when we started started recording people
as they entered rooms and as we did
primarily close quarters combat scenarios.
So you've got guys in tight quarters and
they're making very quick decisions and
you start seeing what you look like and
it, and it makes you better. You know?
That's why that's one of the reasons why
you do it is same thing with Jujitsu.
You've watched the tape or or MMA,
you watched the tape of what
someone's doing it. Football,
they do that in every sport, right? They
watched the tape, see what you look like,
see what mistakes you made.
So when someone hits you with something
that's disturbing or it's going to cause
problems,
picture that you're being recorded and
you're going to have to watch the play by
play later with your
team and look at what,
how much you lost your temper or how
much you got frazzled and what a disaster
you were. So I, that's
what I would picture.
Or as you start to move
in the direction of a,
I'm not going to get frazzled by problems,
I'm just going to listen.
I'm going to assess,
I'm going to make decisions
and move forward. Yeah, yeah.
Pretty recent. Yeah. Pretty
simple. Dang. Yeah, that, that
play when they play glyphs,
go to the videotape, you know, let's play
in football or man and meeting. They'd,
you know,
big screen projector.
Get Echo the little laser pointer.
Yes, exactly. So when men,
when you mess up and everyone's looking,
what are you doing here?
They pause it and it shows you like
mid mess up. You know what man? It's,
it's like they put you on the stage
and just thrilled tomatoes at you.
That's what it feels like. That's how
you get better though. Yeah. Agree.
Totally agree.
And in a way I told you I used to do
this where it had to do with more like
getting mad. Like if I find
myself getting mad, you know,
same thing over reaction kind of where
I'd really shame myself kind of like,
man, that's embarrassing.
You got mad kind of thing.
So it would be on my mind the whole
time where anytime I felt myself getting
mad, it'd be on my mind. Like all look
at me, I'm being one of those guys.
So it's kind of the same thing, but it's
in your own head kind of thing. Yeah.
And it's, it really boils
down to something I talk about
all the time. Detachment.
Yeah. That's what I'm talking about.
Being able to picture yourself.
What do I look like right now?
Am I appearing to be a panicked
stricken loser or an a calm,
cool, collected leader that's going
to step up and make a good decision,
assessed the situation and move forward.
Let's look like that guy.
Go winter heater. What about if
you're like, what? Uh, what uh,
what about if you're tired?
Like you didn't get it.
A lot of sleep for a few days. Serious
right now. No factor Nova. Okay.
It doesn't affect you. You know, people
in what your uncle people get irritable.
You get tired. Yeah. Which I
actually find a music. Yeah.
But that's a real thing. That is
a real thing. You know, it's like,
you know what that means?
You need to, if you,
if you're one of those people
that's going to be in that mode,
you need to be aware of that and you need
to focus even more on not overreacting
and acting like a baby because you're
tired. And that could be, yeah, exactly.
That's a good one. Like a baby, like
a baby. Yeah. What does the baby do?
You start crying. Yes. And that's actually
kind of the point there where, you know,
I used to be one of the,
before I had kids,
you know how when the kid is acting up,
you know your friend's kid is acting up
and then you're like, oh, on a bratty kid.
But the parent of the kid
that always is like, oh,
he's just tired or she's just tired. And
you're like, you thought it was a lie.
No. Know your kid is a brat. That's
what you, you kind of think you know,
your kid's not tired.
I'll always judging you.
I think most people without you,
that's how,
and after awhile you,
especially when you have kids,
you start to realize,
oh
m and there's a difference in kids'
behavior and may must be fundamental.
Cause this is a one year old
we're talking about, you know,
it's not like he learned to
start crying when he's tired.
It's like when you're tired you just
less patient ease. Even as an adult,
you ever been tired and you're like
waiting for something, whatever. Bro.
When you're,
when you're tired and you're waiting for
something and it's not coming like as
quick as you expected
and what you're used to.
Here's the problem that I run in with
with waiting or being held up or when I,
this is how I realized
I was a control freak.
A kind of is going to the airport because
if you're running late in the airport,
you can't control Tsa.
They're going to take,
and of course if,
if I'm on time for my flight to waiting
in the TSA line for five minutes is not
a big deal at all.
If I'm late for my flight,
five minutes is an eternity in their
pathetic and they're losers and they're
slow and it's all on me.
It's all on me cause I went to
the airport late so I'm not,
I get to the airport early cause I don't
like to have the feeling of things I
can't control. So I'm going
to do the best to mitigate it.
That's one of those situations if you
get all tired and then you get all angry
and you start crying like a baby,
then guess what?
Get more sleep and or,
and,
or cause sometimes you don't have
the choice and you get less sleep.
So put yourself in check and try and
get control those emotions instead of
acting like a baby. Yeah, I put
in in the warrior could book,
one of the lines is mark,
he's all bummed out in the line was
he started crying like a baby and,
and, and the, the editors
were like, you know,
you might not want to say that.
You know,
it kind of gives a bad thing
about applying. His name's
pat and Koreans babyish.
And I said,
well no actually you're crying like a
baby and babies cry and you know when
you're a 10 year old kid you
shouldn't be crying like a baby.
And it's him saying about
himself, you know. So they,
they were a little
sensitive about that one.
But once I kind of debriefed him on
it, we look good. The line remained.
Mark in his own words broke down
and started crying like a baby.
So yeah,
cause crying like a baby technically is
not the same thing is just normal crying
for stuff. Yeah, that's true.
I'm just trying to like,
because why they say crying like a baby?
Really?
It's probably cause babies cry
for literally everything. Right.
Anything that they're not strict about
the baby crying cause he doesn't know how
to talk. So if you're crying like a baby
crying, screaming for every little thing,
there you go. But if you're just crying
over Hawaii five o or, or you know,
whatever the movie is you're watching,
then that's different.
You know what I'm saying? The line
remained. That's the good thing.
That's the key right there.
Next question.
Any advice for a second lieutenant?
One month into IOC and a couple of
months from standing in front of up Plt
platoon, platoon of marines for
the first time? You know what?
I almost didn't answer this one because
I answered it all the time for every
different person that's
going into leadership isn't,
but I'm going to answer it one more time
just to make sure I'm going to make it
brief and to make it quick. But if you're
going into a new leadership position,
whether you're going to be in charge
of a Marine Corps platoon or an army
platoon or a seal platoon or a
division at a company or a sports team,
whatever, you're gonna be in charge of
that. The principles are the same, right?
We're going to be humble. Number
one, we're going to listen.
We're not going to act like
we know everything cause
we don't because we're new.
There's gonna be a a gunny sergeant in
that platoon that actually does know all
lot of stuff. You don't, you don't
need to go in there asking him,
acting like you do. You're going to
take suggestions, you're going to,
you're going to ask for advice,
you're going to heed the
advice when it comes your way.
Now you're going to work harder than
everybody else that that goes without
saying. You're gonna outwork everybody.
They're going to respect that,
and then when the time comes to be
decisive and you've taken on board,
do the various inputs, you're going to
be decisive. Once you've been decisive,
that doesn't mean that you're going
to hold on and burn in with that idea,
that decision that you made,
you can change your mind sometimes.
That's the one thing that always
freaked me out about politicians when a
politician would change their
mind and it wouldn't say, oh,
they're a flip flopper. They
change their mind. You know,
born information comes to light and
your attitude can, can evolve. You know,
your opinion can evolve. That's not,
that's not a horrible thing to me. Now,
if you have somebody that's flip flopping
their fundamental principles that can
obviously,
and if the reason for them doing
that isn't for new information,
it's because they want this person or
that group of people to vote for me.
Well then that's obviously
a different thing.
But for you to analyze your decision
and then let it mature and change,
that's not that big of a deal. And
it's, and, and people get paranoid that,
that your troops won't respect that.
Like I said,
we were going to come in for the west,
so we're just not going to change my
mind cause I'll look weak. No, no, no.
You actually look week by maintaining
a stupid opinion or maintaining course
that's a bad course or a bad
decision. So, so don't do that.
Just be humble, be decisive when you have
to be, or when you, when you need to be.
And then also,
remember there's been all these
other leaders throughout history,
thousands and thousands of years that
have stepped up and taking charge of stuff
and got an after it.
So you're gonna make some mistakes.
So is everybody. The people that are,
that you're working for made mistakes too.
That gunnery sergeant made mistakes,
you know, he wasn't perfect.
So you're going to make mistakes. No, not,
not that big of a deal and make a
mistake. What do you do? Own it.
Learn from it.
Move forward.
So that's what you do with the new
leadership position and good luck,
man. The platoon commander, platoon
commander, platoon commander,
that's what you want to be and
that's what you got. Go and get it.
Semper fi and thanks for
your service. Yeah, that's,
I think that's one.
My opinion is that the,
this question and this answered that you
just gave that I don't think that gets
old because that's a hard one. It
and no one feels comfortable. Yeah.
Actually, let me rephrase that.
The people that feel comfortable,
I'm ready to get in there and take charge.
They're generally the least ready and
are going to have the worst performance
because their,
their,
their ego's big and they believe that
they're going to crush it. This guy,
this second lieutenant, he is humble.
He's aware, he's, you know, hey man,
what can I do? How can it
be ready for this? That's,
that's the perfect place to be at
like a healthy amount of doubt.
Lafe Lafe told that story a couple of
times where when he was the executive
officer to seal team or the
ops officer to seal team,
if he called out and I
was running training,
so his seal team was going through
training and he would call, you know,
the platoon commander of the troop
commander. And he'd say, Hey, you know,
how's everything going out there? And if
he, if they answered were crushing it,
life would say, oh we got issues
cause, cause factually he knew,
he knew, he know. He knew
I was running training.
There wasn't anyone's going
to crush the training running.
And so if their answer
wasn't, you know, hey,
the training is really hard and we're
doing our best, we're learning a lot.
Those guys, he'd say okay, they're good
to go and I'll go see him, you know,
in a week or so. If they said they
were crushing it, he'd say, yeah,
I'm going to come out and see you guys
tomorrow. And then when they get up there,
he'd say, what's going on? It's
like, yeah, it's not good. So yeah,
that attitude of we're crushing it is
generally an indicator of you're probably
not doing the best job.
So stay humble indicator of how they're
going to move forward to, you know,
like their attitude and looking for work.
Gosh, I'm doing great. Yeah, no time.
No you're not.
You're not doing great.
None of us are at a minimum
we can do better. Right.
So the minute you say I'm doing
great. Yeah. Going backwards.
Next question.
How long did it take you to get promoted
to a blue belt and how often were you
training during that time?
So real simple question.
It took me,
I think about nine or 10 months
to get my blue belt cheap Paula.
And when I was at that
time I ah, I was at, yeah,
at seal team one,
I was in the training department and I
had a lot of opportunity to train at that
time.
Clinton years.
Not a lot of money to train
that in the seal teams.
So less trips, shorter trips, less travel.
So we were staying around a little bit
more, no war going on, on top of all that.
So we were, we were home a
little bit more. And so I
trained all the time. I try,
I would go to lunch at lunch, I
would zip over to Fabio Santos. Okay.
And train the lunchtime class.
And then I'd sit back and do
work and then we'd get done.
I'd go back and I would do the beginner
class and then I would do the advanced
class.
And then I would roll with Dean and
Higgs and James Nielsen in Craig and the
rest of the guys that were there
at Fabio's at the time. And we,
and Fabio used to kick dean and I off
the Mat at like nine o'clock at night.
Take it too long. Yeah. And he'd
say, why don't you guys get a life?
Why do you do it? And we'd say, we're just
writing the duty to say, we got a life.
It's right here. Yeah, I'm
living. This is it. It did.
And so it was mostly at Fabio's like you
know how you said you'd like train with
your, you know, your guys who
weren't trained to whatever
was there that going on?
Yeah. Yeah. Anybody that
wanted a roll with me,
I had the same policy that
I have right now. You wanna
roll. Cool. Yeah, let's roll.
Well I have my gear,
it's in my bag right now.
If you want to train and we'll try it.
Oh it's Thursday afternoon and it's two
o'clock and we don't have any work to do
and you want to turn cold, we'll try it.
So yeah, I was doing that all the time.
And the thing is once I got blue belt,
cause I think I got blue belt
pretty pretty quickly and,
but I was a blue belt for a
long time because, because I,
right as I was probably getting
close to getting my purple belt,
I left,
I left California and I went to Virginia
Beach once I got to Virginia Beach,
stepped into a new Dojo
with Gustavo Machado.
And you started training with Gustavo
and, and I'm just a blue belt. Right.
And so he's got to know,
learn me and fee figured out
what my personality is like,
see what my potential is as a person.
And I trained really hard there,
but I was also gone a lot traveling and
that's when I was traveling a lot on the
road and I would train with guys on
the road and it went on deployment,
trained with guys on deployment and
then it would come back into town.
And so I didn't get consistent enough
with him eyes with him where he said, hey,
this guy's ready for his purple Belch.
So by the time I might've
been close to him thinking,
okay, you know what I mean? You
start looking to him for purple belt,
went back to San Diego, got
back to San Diego, and now,
now I check back into Fabio's.
Well it's been two years, bro.
You need to, you, we know you
need to prove yourself again.
So it was almost like I
was at the bottom of the,
of the pecking order in
terms of time in rain,
even though I'd been a
blue belt for a long time.
So I ended up being a
I want to say it was a blue
belt for maybe like five years.
Yeah. And I was a good blue
belt. Don't get me wrong sir.
Of course who were and but you know there
was a long time when you jump around
from school to school and the instructor
doesn't know you well enough and
doesn't see you on a regular basis
and can assess your employment.
Cause that's the thing with
Jujitsu in my opinion, for your,
you don't get your,
there's not a level playing field
for every person. So in other words,
it's not,
hey these are the skills required for
blue belt and now you get your blue belt
and then you've learned these other for,
you know,
these other hundred and 27 other
moves and now you get your purple bow.
Now there's 310 moves to get your,
it's not like that at all.
And in fact it's also not,
hey,
how do you as a blue belt do against this
other group of blue belts? What it is,
and I know this sounds a
little bit cliche, but it's,
it's really how good are you against you,
right?
Because if somebody you know,
you,
let's say you get somebody that starts
with Jujitsu when they're older,
you know,
maybe they're 55 years old,
they're going to go and they train
until they're 62 or their training and
training and training, their skill
level, they're getting injured,
they're having issues, they
gotta work, they got up,
they get up and do a bunch of other
things and they can't, they're a hobbyist,
right? They're not focused and
they can only train so much.
They learned the moves, they
get better. 10 years go by,
there's a chance that they're going to
be a black belt based on the fact that
hey,
as a 55 year old person that came in
here and started training and moves that
you've learned and how you've applied
them according to your athletic ability
and your physical capability at
the time, Hey, it's been 10 years,
which is a pretty rough number for like,
you know, for getting your black belt.
So that's acceptable.
But you might get a kid that's a really
good athlete that in two years can
destroy that guy. Yeah. And he's not
getting his black belt because you're,
you're saying what is your potential?
How good can you be as a black belt?
That's the question.
So really it's almost a compliment.
The longer it takes you to get your
belts, that means, in my opinion,
that means the better you're going to,
that means the better that your instructor
thinks you're going to be. That's my,
that's my thought. And not everyone
does it like that. And you know,
some people think, oh, if, if this purple
belt can be that purple belt, you know,
this purple belts better.
And if this purple belt can beat the
Brown belt than I need to give him his
brown belt. Not Too many things
people think that way. You know,
who thinks that way? The purple
belt, I can meet the Brown belt,
I should be a brown belt.
No wrong. So, so true.
And this, so many. Um,
there's so many of those little things
like the reason an instructor might be
influenced to give,
I mean typically they're not going to
give someone a belt based solely on the
fact that he taps out that,
you know, Brown belt. So,
but it is influenced by that is
there's all these weird things.
There's stuff like sometimes I'm watching
like a two blue belts and they'll see
that I'm watching and it turns into
a death match. What's APP actually,
you know what, that's, I just saw
a video of a guy with a commuter.
I think you put it on on social media.
What kind of injured his elbow.
You think cause look like his elbow.
Yeah.
Maybe like crap didn't tap to the
camera. The camera is a beast, man.
You come here as a beast, you know,
you can not tap to a foot lock.
You can not tap too. You can even
not tap to a heal hook. Yeah,
he'll hook can go really sideways,
but you don't have to come euro and
you're probably gonna have some issues.
It's so terrible to watch. Like,
I think as I get their, you know,
their knee and stuff in a heel hook
and it's like, it's like, oh Dang that.
But man, the camera when you see the
guys arm just doesn't that way. Man.
I did it post that video
that someone else it,
I would never post videos like that.
In fact, I don't like don't watch that.
I saw what I've,
is that what I did to your shoulder
according to the success almost separated
your shoulder separated and
did not people not do that.
I know it sounded nice and dramatic,
but it didn't happen.
I don't think you've ever almost
that's I'll do my shoulder. Yeah.
But as far as,
as far as people getting
instructors getting influenced
on why to give guys belt
or a higher belt, like some instructors
for example, the bill be influenced now,
but uh,
to give a guy hired belt because I
want to have more black belts under me.
You know,
we have a team of black
belts and typically that'll
have a lot to do with sales.
You know, like where I can be like, Hey,
I have, you know, a team of, you know,
and I've heard the sales pitch, you know,
where it's like, hey, we have seven,
seven black belts on the mat, three world
champ. You know, that's good. That's good.
So people might be influenced by
that. And then there'll be like, okay,
maybe I'll give these two guys they're
belt cause and so now we have four black
belts or whatever. There's that. And
then if that's the reason, you know,
I mean it is good to have 10 black
belts in your association that is,
give it to the gym. Yeah, for sure.
And, but then there's the opposite too,
or guys will be like,
if they're at,
and this typically happens if they're
competing. So if a coach is like a,
I got these five brown belts,
they're obviously on the level of
black belt knowledge, performance,
all this stuff. But when they go into
the tournament in the brown belt level,
we got gold medals,
gold team medals every time.
So then there's that situation
again. Sandbagging. Exactly.
Right. So there's, yeah,
there's all those things in regards
to the belt. I said this before,
I'm gonna say it again.
The belt really doesn't have to do with
how good you think you are or how good
even you know you are.
If you're like, Hey,
I'm tapping, you know, I'm
a white belt. For example,
I'm a white belt and I'm
hanging with the purple belt.
I'm tapping blue belts and brown belts
are gay. I'm giving them a hard time
so I should be a blue belt.
It doesn't matter. Doesn't
matter at all. And you know,
it sounds like an exaggeration.
It doesn't matter.
It all new to us a little bit
here was saying, no, it doesn't.
Your skill is evaluated
by your instructor.
That's the reason why you can
be at a certain level, leave,
come back and still not be because your,
your instructor,
you can be quite dominating everywhere.
The instructor has to evaluate that.
So that's exactly what happened with me.
And it wasn't a negative thing.
It was like, Hey, you've
been gone for two years.
We got to see where you're at Jocko.
And it's not just one day being either
back in here and get your purple belt just
because you've been training
for two straight years. Yeah.
It doesn't matter. Yeah.
I know what's interesting too is this,
obviously this applies to
people in the business world.
People trying to get promoted and
and the more you're thinking, Hey, I,
I'm better at this job than
this guy should get. There's
something else going on.
There's something that you look at and
the more frustrated you get about not
getting that promotion, not getting
taken care of, not getting noticed,
just do your job,
work hard.
You know the don't worry about the
promotion and approach promotions going to
come in most cases.
Yeah.
So mine was,
I wouldn't even frame it where I would
say in all cases there are exceptions
like everything else, but in, in
all cases, that is the situation.
And think about this too, when you, when
you, in regards to like your belt, right?
Do you get to belt?
If I'm a white belt Jocko year,
my instructor and I'm like,
Hey, I'm winning all these
tournaments, all of them.
Gold nut, a point score,
all by submission.
I'm talking about blue belt and
purple belt sometimes. Hey Jocko,
gimme my blue belt. I can't do
that. You, you, it's not up to me.
Even if I beg you, I go on the
Internet, I post this petition,
it's not up to me. See,
this is, this is the thing,
you know when you hear in martial arts,
like old traditional martial arts,
like you will learn humility.
Yeah.
And you will learn discipline and they
would teach it. You know, by teaching it,
by talking about it in
Jujitsu, it's real. Yeah. Look,
you will be humble and
when you flare up and say,
where's my belt? That's you not being
humble. That's you. Not just saying, Hey,
I need to work harder. I need
to keep getting after it. Yeah.
And so you're learning that lesson
and that's part of the lesson.
This was the way it she'll
be. You know, and again, I,
I've mentioned this before on the podcast,
just because someone is a Jujitsu person,
just because they're a black belt
doesn't mean they have the same.
That doesn't mean they have
like the best morals and values.
It doesn't mean that at all.
There can be people selling belts.
There's people that sell belt.
Oh you,
you going to take 10 privates with
me $1,000 each and then, then you'll,
that's how you get the black
belt. Okay, cool. No, not cool.
As soon as a bunch of things
like that too, you know, oh,
I want you to go open a pilot
school for me somewhere,
so I'm going to give you your black belt.
You're not that good.
So that way you can, you
can give me my, you know,
12% of your annual earnings and
things like that happen and there's,
you know,
even worse things that happened.
But the bottom line is
an impure jujitsu sense.
You should be working hard and
getting promoted as it comes from your
instructor.
Yeah.
So essentially the promote this sort of
like an indirect way of you talking to
me about your belt, but no, not
at all actually. Actually it,
if it does apply to me,
I say it doesn't matter.
You don't even care well less
than anyone cares or doesn't care.
Of course I think everyone
cares in one way or another.
But I'd say the approach it more has
to do with the approach. Like just like
how you said, focus on getting better
folks on the learning. That's it.
The belt is just a symptom
of your learning. It's a,
it's an eventuality essentially.
Same thing or back to the fact that
doesn't have anything to do with the Co,
the person. Only the instructor. On the
flip side of what I said about, you know,
if I think I'm, I've, I think I'm a blue
belt and I'm not getting my blue belt,
what's up? It's not up to me. It's
something instructor. No matter what.
Same thing is if you, you're like,
hey, promotion time. Hey Echo,
here's your blue belt. And I'm like, I'm
not ready for this. Bluebell. I suck. I'm,
I can't even do this. Well,
I can't give the belt back.
I can't like take it off and
then put it, you know, I mean,
I'm sure there's some kind of excitement.
There was that thing that happened
long time ago with, um, with ensign.
There wasn't a loss. It was like a year
ago. Yeah. That's a long time ago. Okay.
But nonetheless, you know, I can't give
it back to you. When you get demoted,
you're ready for it.
So put your belt on and start,
start getting after it has nothing
to do with your opinion. That's the,
that's the point there. So yeah, it's your
inner strength to keep training. Yeah.
Because sometimes people get their belts
and they stopped training. Yeah. That,
and that's an India.
Here's the thing,
all admit there was a point in my life
where I was like, concerned about that.
I'm like, well, I'm, you know, I'm better
than this guy. I'm not going to say when,
which belt? It was not recently
mind you, but like three weeks ago,
I guess I shouldn't say it, but then I
remember and when I think about that time,
man, I wasn't learning that much at all.
I was just focusing on like, whoa, good.
I do. So like, you know, your game kind
of is closed off. You don't learn much.
You're concerned about, you know,
all this stuff and if he's happy,
he's exactly right. Your risks not
learning. Yes, exactly right and gets you.
And it just messes up your whole
Jujitsu experience because you had that,
you have that added, added element
of stress. It's not good. Do that.
Don't even ask about belts. I
think that's a good, that isn't,
that is a great policy that
that's the best policy for belts.
Don't ask him to train hard and you'll
get what's coming to you eventually.
But sometimes people will ask you, hey,
when are you going to get your blue belt?
Or you know, you know, people will ask you
that whenever, I dunno. Yeah, whatever.
My instructor asked me what I'm
gonna get the red and black belt.
I'll just kidding. No one
asked me that. The Coral Belle.
Interesting. Yeah. Good. Next question.
What's the best approach to
managing people that outperform you?
Okay.
I think this is a simple question as well.
What you do in this situation is you
give them all the support you can and let
them run. I'm, I'm happy if someone's
outperform me. That's great.
You know what do I'll do? Try and learn
from him and see what they're doing.
I'll try and spread the word.
If I'm in a leadership
position in someone's doing
outperforming everyone, great.
How can we take that?
How can we teach to everyone else?
How can I give them support so
they can re run even faster?
This is no factor to me.
I love it.
You should be surrounding the more people
you can bring on your team that how
perform you,
the better you're going to do.
True
check. Easy money. Next
question. Next. Yeah.
A lot of times it's hard though. You
know, and I know you're going to say ego.
Oh, am I going to say it that boy, is
it not true? We know it's your ego.
It's 100% of you go when you can't support
somebody that's doing better than you.
It's 100% ego. Why else
would you not support them?
They're helping the team win.
They're helping everyone do better.
Why would you not support them?
Because your ego, because
you're like, Ooh, that hurts.
Yeah, I want to be the guy.
And you know what you look like.
Then you look like a jealous baby,
little baby word of the day,
baby.
You literally look jealous little baby
because you're trying to hold them back
and everyone can see it and everyone
can tell it. Just don't be that person.
That's a good point right there.
Everyone can tell what's going on.
It's one of those dichotomies is,
is that people can be so ignorant to
things and yet so perceptive to things.
Yeah. So and the things like that,
they're so perceptive to echo,
doesn't like to see Jocko out shine him.
That's why he's trying to hold them back
or he's not sending him on that trip.
We're just going to win that deal. Oh,
he's going to go instead. Yeah. Hey,
I won the deal guys.
Yeah, I'm great, no wrong.
And even down to the smallest little
things like you know, hey, um, you know,
I don't know. We'll see. John
is against your subordinate.
You're jealous of him
because he's cause he's dope.
And when someone gives John a
compliment about how good he did,
just the little looking on your face.
So obvious you don't know.
And you know how you say some people are,
are people are so like ignorant of
some things in silver perceptive.
They're ignorant about this stuff. When
it applies to them, he was somebody else.
It's like, Oh yeah, I'll point
those out all day. Good points.
Like when people in the, I got
this Sam Harris, he pointed,
he had this example where name dropping
when you're, you know, when you,
when you do some name dropping, not
everyone, but most people, it's like,
it's easier to recognize it when
other people need drop the one they do
themselves, you know, it's so
funny. All chill in theirs.
If I name drop,
I immediately feel like
flush of just disgust is,
oh my God, that's so bad.
Yeah. Yeah. It's true.
So bad. But it's hard to kind of know
to, you know, you know, speaking of that,
I was just texting back and forth with
Tim Ferriss and Joe Rogan the other day
named job. I'm just kidding.
That's how you know that's a,
that's a um, excessive name drop when
you say their first and their last,
that's it. You know, and then
we'll, I don't know what's
worse. I was just texting.
I just got a text from Tim. He was
letting me know about that. Yeah,
you're a Tim who? Tim
Ferriss. Joe Hogan. My boy.
We were kicking it old
school that's like, um, uh,
like pseudo advanced name dropping where,
where uh,
you say the first name like that,
but like,
like amateur named dropping
his first and last name. Okay.
So I was actually black belt
namedropping he just first name,
first name base. Actually more like
one straight white belt. You know,
it's just a little bit more advanced.
It's still namedropping is,
what's the height?
Is there a way to appropriately namedrop
somehow? How do you do that? Right.
I'm sure they did not say their name.
I was talking to someone the other day,
so this is a similar situation.
I was talking to, you know, met
some people the other day and, and,
and the girl says, you
will, you know I, oh yeah.
We were talking about the east coast
and she's, Oh yeah. I went to college,
I went to college in Cambridge and it
was, you know, it's, it's a good place.
And I was thinking of myself,
I didn't, I, you know, Oh,
where'd you go to school? No,
we'll leave it at that. Yeah. But
that was sort of a high level job.
I lived in Cambridge. That's where
I went to college all in one call.
Just talk about going on out
there. Right, right. You know. Oh,
was that a high level, was it or was
that just an honest conversation? Yeah.
It might've been, just might've been
just her not wanting to sound like,
yeah,
you know, hey, you don't,
right. She didn't want to,
she didn't essentially want to name
drop for the reason that people normally
named job.
But here's what I think there is a
weighted like effectively in like
legitimately if for lack
of a better term name drop.
And that's like if you, if you cause
namedropping typically, so you know,
it's almost like a weak attempt
at breezing over, you know,
I'm fixing with Joe Rogan or they'll
like say their little credentials.
But I think if you say,
you know,
I was texting with my friend
and he was actually Joe Rogan,
you know that and you make it like a
point the size that this wasn't just
anyone. It was Joe. You're actually
excited about it. Yes. You know? Exactly.
So that I think that's an
effective way cause it Kinda,
you kinda can maintain your humility
there. Yeah. But you don't want to be,
we're like, you know, I'm just
texting with my boy Joe Rogan,
whatever kind of thing where like I'm
just no big deal. No big deal. That's,
it'd be diva anyway. Cool. Wait,
I digress. Yeah. All right, next question.
Okay.
What would be a good
approach to effectively
what would be a good approach
to effectively leading
a team where instead of
taking ownership of their responsibilities
and working towards team goals,
each team member is just
trying to be the boss.
Okay, so a couple things here. Eat, eat.
You want to let them be the
boss of their tasks, right?
That's what you're trying to do. So that,
that makes sense. And one of the ways,
if they're,
if they want to be the boss of everything,
maybe you give them a little bit more
as much decision making process that you
can as to what tasks or what
projects they're in charge of.
So that makes them feel a little bit like
they're empowered and I shouldn't say,
makes them feel like they're empowered.
You actually are empowered. Yeah.
You know what I mean?
So there's a,
there's a pretty significant
distinction because once again,
people will recognize if you're just
letting them do it to make them feel good
about it, they're going to know
that. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Jocko,
thanks for the decision. You gave
me a choice of one thing. Thank you.
The color of the hens we're
using. So, so you know,
maybe let them really there
a 40 in leadership on owning
what it is that they're
owning.
But the question says they're not taking
ownership of their responsibilities.
So let's make sure first that we're not,
that,
that we're giving them full reign and
full ownership of their responsibilities
and we're not micro managing in there.
Now if that,
if we're beyond that and,
and we got people that just want
to be in charge of the whole thing.
Well cool. That's,
that's actually awesome.
You want to be in charge of
everything of Echo is a isn't it?
Our team and he wants to be in
charge of everything. Hey guys,
check it out right now.
This next project that we're working,
echo is going to run it.
I'm going to sit back and by the way,
next project bill, you're running
and next project, Fred, year running.
Now we're all going to get to actually
get in the hot seat and he and I,
I'll tell you what you're going to see.
Number one,
you're gonna see some people that go,
they wanted to sit in the back of Cerp
but they don't actually want to be
responsible for anything, so that puts
them to rest right away. You're also,
what's going to happen with everybody
is they're all going to see that this
thing that looks so easy from the back
of the room is a lot harder than they
think. That's what it's
like running a seal mission.
The guy in the back that's never
been in charge before. It's like, oh,
we should just do it like this.
Yeah. And that guy, you say, okay,
here you run this, and then you know,
in six hours they come up and say, Hey,
oh yeah,
you give me a head with how we were
supposed to contact and deconflict with
these other units. Oh, okay. It's
a little trickier than you thought.
Maybe isn't it?
But you actually put people in charge of
things if they want to be in charge of
things, put them in charge of
things. It's great. And you know,
don't let them fall on her face. Don't
let him get anyone killed. Don't let him,
you know, get anyone he injured
or lose any strategic ground.
We're not going to do that,
but we're going to let them have the
opportunity to step up and lead it if they
do a good job. Sweet.
Sweet. Now you've got them.
You can rely on them. You can actually
put them in charge of projects.
Now you don't have to micromanage. We
don't have to watch over them. This is a,
this is a no lose situation.
This happened actually one of my,
one of my platoon was going through
training and one of the platoon commanders
came up to me.
We were just putting them in a platoon
through training and he comes up and he's,
Oh, my platoon chief wants to
run everything, and I said, good.
Let him run everything. Let him
run everything. That's perfect.
Then you can focus on, you know, other
things. Don't worry about it, but ego,
right? We want to be running everything
we want the, I'm, I'm the guy in charge.
Yeah. No, let him run it.
And it's just, it's, it's,
it's the,
the reason,
the thing that holds people back from
letting other people run things is
insecurity. If I think echo is
going to do a better job than me,
or I think you're gonna do a really
good job and you're going to shine,
and I don't feel like I do a good job,
I'm gonna hold you back.
Is the best of my ability to be
like, no. I go, oh, you go ahead.
You go ahead and just stay in your lane.
They're putting that piece over here. No,
but if I, if I, if I know, if
I'm secure in my leadership man,
Echo, oh, you want to run this
dude? Awesome. Here you go.
Here's the plan. Once you,
you know, here's the, here's
the portfolio. Why don't
you put the plan together?
I'm going to be over here looking down
the road on their next project and
looking for our next
song thing down the road,
going out and getting another
client to bring into the game.
We're going to make this happen. No
factor. Yeah. Seems like counterintuitive,
isn't it? Yeah, it is. You
want to, you want me to say,
here's how your keep the people in
their lanes. Yes, exactly. Yeah.
I'm going to tell you what you do.
Let them out of their lands.
Let them into your lane.
Let him run some stuff.
Build a new leader to beautiful thing.
When you, you know, when
you're insecure you want,
you don't want them to shout
out, shine you. You know?
You can tell that where I think
it's natural though. You know,
when people maybe a little insecure,
you know,
or if you're not as good
as maybe you hope or what.
I think it's natural to be a little
bit insecure. Of course. Here's how,
here's how, in my experience anyway, where
I could tell where I'm being insecure,
where if someone's performing a
certain thing and you're kind of like,
you can feel it consciously, you kind
of hope that they don't do that good,
but man that I know, rats bad, it's bad.
But that's how you can tell them how you
can tell you. If you have that feeling,
you should. You should
definitely, if you have that
feeling, check yourself. Go, God,
you know what,
here I am hoping that my own team
member I know doesn't do a good job.
Yeah,
that's fast and bad situation real bad.
You want to hope everyone's doing great.
Yeah.
And you know this happened on deployment
and I talk about it in the book.
Extreme ownership was, you know,
the Delta platoon commander,
he was worried that this element
that had come in to work in his AOE,
he was worried that they were going to
be better than him and take his job.
And he told me that and I said, hey
bro, if they take your job, good,
I'll find a new job for you.
There's so much work we got work to do.
Don't worry about it.
Help them,
help them take your job and
I'll find you a new job.
It turns out that their egos were too
big and they couldn't let that happen.
But that's the same situation.
You've got somebody that thinks is going
to take your job and do better than you.
Help them and then find new work cause
cause we're trying to help the team.
Right.
There's a mission,
there's overall mission and echo can
do something better than me. Hey,
here's the turnover.
Here's the lessons I learned.
You're better at this than I am.
You keep running with it.
I'm going to go find something that
I'm good at or an area that I can help.
That's just supporting the
whole team. That's a window. So,
and you know what,
sitting in the podcast studio,
it's so easy to talk about that,
but it's so hard for people to do that.
It really is really is one of those things
where you're dealing with your actual
feelings in the situation.
We're not dealing with our actual feelings
in situation right now, but which,
but it doesn't that mean that
it's, that's good. You know,
you're giving a fresh view. You are,
yeah. You know you are detached,
accurate advice and the more detached,
and you pointed out some red flags, right?
If I'm hoping that these guys
go on the mission and fail,
that's a red flag that you're
being selfish and insecure
about your job and what
you're doing. And if someone can do a
job better than you, let them do it,
that's going to help the whole team.
Yeah,
so it's like your us in the
podcast room, we're like, you know,
if you get a guy in the maze,
the maze of emotions and we're
outside of the mains on top,
we can see the whole maze. We're not in
the middle of emotions. We're on top.
We can look at the whole scenario,
the homeys so we can tell that
guy what to do effectively. Echo,
you just described detachment.
There you go with detachment is like that.
That's what, that's what, that's
what it's like for me. Yeah.
I can see the maze and I remember learning
how to step back and step above and
look to mace. I remember. Yeah, I
remember learning that and going, oh,
that's all I've got to do.
Yeah.
And then I remember taking it from the
training ground the battlefield and then
realizing that that's what you need to
do in the everyday interactions with
people. And especially once
I got in the business world.
The thing that was cool about
when we started echelon front,
now I would be witnessing like we, I'd go
into a meeting and I would be detached.
I would be up above the maze of emotions
in turmoil and so now I would get to
see it and then I would start
bringing the leadership and saying,
look at what this looks like to me.
You know, they'd go, I don't like that.
I don't like that one too.
The video to go into the video and,
and so then that's how you learn.
We didn't go to the video.
Look what it looks like from up
above the maze and now you see,
you see what you were
doing here in your meeting.
You had everybody so intimidated
that no one's said anything.
You just gave a 15 minute meeting.
No one responded in any
way to anything you said.
Do you think everyone in that room agreed
with everything you said? Not a chance.
They didn't say a word. Why is that
you intimidated them, you bullied them,
and now you're not getting any feedback
and they're going to execute the plan
that they don't believe in.
And that's probably less effective than
the one that they have coming from the
field. Yeah. Congratulations.
Congratulations. No
knock. Congratulations.
Let's get this fixed. Congratulate
like, you know, so, uh,
I was in the, in traffic,
in some of the things about,
I was in traffic and you know how
the, you have the two lanes, right?
So I'm going to turn left on the
light in the lane next to me.
They're going straight.
So whoever the person in front of
the person that was next to me,
both Queen Street,
they were taking too long.
So the lady next honking the horn, all
credit, like going like this, all crazy.
So of course I look over at it and
she's going crazy. She looks over at me.
She's like, like, do you believe this
kind of thing all by nuts. Meanwhile,
I'm looking at myself, you know, other
people around me, they're just like, well,
this lady's going nuts.
You know?
So that's an example of being
on the outside looking in her.
She thought it was justifiable
honking the horn looking nuts,
but meanwhile we're on the
outside looking at her like, Bro,
you know how you look and you
know what that situation is.
You didn't have to be,
she did well.
Is that a red light? She was.
You know what I'm saying though?
She's a person that hadn't left for late
work late and she was going to be in
trouble and blah, blah blah, and that
that 30 seconds that that ten second,
that eight seconds, it was probably
like three was an attorney for her.
She's just going nuts.
Just like I was talking about the airport.
If I'm running late for the flight,
TSA takes five minutes.
It could be no factor or it could drive
me completely insane meal and that's,
that was her, and you know what?
These days when I screw something up,
I don't get frustrated like that. You
know? That's what we're talking about.
The first question, I'm like, oh
my God, I look at myself and God,
I can't believe I left late to do this.
I'm an idiot.
I won't let that happen again.
I said that in 1996 and I
haven't had to let it happen. So
see what I mean though,
I was outside.
The main thing I know she
didn't know how she's feeling.
These guys not going goal greenlight
go. It's time to go universal. Yeah.
So I understand the feeling, but look
how you look from the outside. You know,
did she check herself at
all? No. When she saw you,
she looked at to me for some emotional
support as if you believe this guy,
you know, get crazy with me kind
of thing. That was the look.
Yeah man. It's like dig it.
That's, I think that's another, uh,
understand the difference between
feeling and behavior as well. You know,
like I feel, I know that's a
frustrating thing. It can be,
but don't behave like that.
Calm down person. Next question.
What have you learned about yourself or
learn in general over the course of the
last 70 plus podcasts?
So the,
the biggest thing that I learned have
learned in the past 70 podcasts is that I
have a lot more to learn.
That's what I learned and the amount of
information out there that will help us
get better and smarter and
more effective as humans.
The amount of information
is is pretty boundless.
And also you also see the
repetitive themes that we
see over and over again that
constantly come up and reinforce
themselves. Now with that,
I think that seeing these repetitive
themes but each with its own little angle
give have given me a better,
I don't want to say a
better understanding,
but I guess I don't know what other word
to use a more granular understanding of
of human nature and of leadership
and of war and of life.
Cause you get to,
nothing teaches better than an experience,
but you can't experience a
thousand years of life in reality.
But through reading and understanding
and seeing what other people have gone
through you,
you do get some level of experience.
I know you just went to, you
just did the, the FTX with,
with echelon front, you went to, did
shoot some video with life and JP.
And for those of you that
don't know Asheville on front,
we do leadership and management consulting
and sometimes we do field training
exercises where we take people out and
we teach them how to shoot and then we
teach them fundamental tactics of fire
maneuver and then we give them missions
to accomplish. And so you know, you, you,
I know you just went out to do your
first one and when you got back,
you notice that you said,
I kind of felt a little bit of what it's
like to be in a firefight and then you
kind of backed off. He like, well,
no I didn't. I didn't, you know,
I'm not trying to say
that. And I said, no,
actually you did feel a little bit of
what it is like to be in a firefight
because you saw people maneuvering
and you, you were getting hit with,
with plastic rounds that hurt and you
knew you need to get down or you saw other
people getting frustrated. You saw
people getting fostered. That's that is,
is it exactly like combat? No.
And there's also a, uh, you know,
the step up to real combat is huge because
now you're going to die if you screw
up. But there is a glimpse and
there is a, there is a, uh,
a certain level of understanding that
you absolutely gain from those scenarios
that you're put into.
And it's the same thing when you read a
book and you read it the right way and
you get gathered the information from it.
You,
you don't have the experience itself, but
there's no doubt you can learn from it.
So I think for me,
that's,
that's the biggest thing is really
reading with a lot of an intent to pull
lessons out.
Seeing the multiple lessons,
seeing the different things
from different angles.
And I've talked about this before.
You know,
when you learn an arm lock from
seven different instructors,
they each teach you something a little
bit different and something that works
and some detail that you didn't see.
And then on top of that,
when you learn an arm lock from the bottom
and from the top and from the garden,
from the closed garden,
from the Open Garden,
from this cross side
and from the mountain,
you every one of those different angles
that you learn it from, you get better.
You get it. Each one of those bangles
makes you better at the other angles too.
So I think that's the biggest thing for
me is just learning how much I didn't
know and then taking what I can bring on
board and assimilating it into my view
and understanding,
like I said,
my view and understanding of
the world of human nature, of
war and of life. Yeah, it's been,
it's been fun for me and educational.
I agree.
I think, I mean obviously I approached
this thing from a different position,
but
you know,
the no complaining thing where
people would be like no complaining.
I think that really got reinforced in me.
It's one of those things where,
what is it? Who said it? Yoda. Where he
says either do or do not. There is no try.
So a little bit different to
see either you'd do it. Yeah.
You had said that power from the star wars
series empire strikes back. Yeah. Okay.
Do or do. There is no try. Got It.
You said a lot of other cool shit.
But nonetheless, when um, you know,
when you're tasked with
something or you're, I dunno,
wife asks you to do something or,
or whatever,
you either do it or you don't do it.
Don't do it in complain about it
the whole time. You know where the,
and that's a common thing where it's a
car, I'll do it and then they'll do it.
Then they'll complain about while they're
doing it or after they do it or before
they do or before, during
and after that, you know.
So it's one of those things where, and
don't even complain in here, this is,
I'm just saying, this is what I've
kind of learned overall and it, it's,
it's weird because this wasn't necessarily
a specific lesson, but it's just,
it Kinda just gets incorporated into
your brain where you just kind of don't
even complain in your own head.
You know, you don't, when you,
when you dunno sweep the floor.
I don't know. You're like,
I can't believe I'm sweeping the floor.
What about all this other stuff that I do
and all this stuff. Don't even do that,
you know? Okay. I'm tasked with just
like how you, it was, you regard it.
You compared it to um, doing paperwork
there. You're like, yeah, but yeah. Good.
You don't want to do paperwork. No,
no one wants to do paperwork. Yeah,
but you do the paperwork and you do
that. Then you crush it. As you say,
you do that paperwork the best
you can crush this paperwork.
Exactly. So man, if I got to sweep the
floor, I got to, you know, wash dishes.
They got whatever,
watch,
I'm going to do this the best I can while
in fact take pride in that you don't
take pride. Not necessarily even in
washing of the dishes. I said, yeah,
take pride in that,
but not necessarily just that.
Take Pride in the fact that you're the
guy who can wash the dishes. That good.
You don't depend on me. Hell yeah,
I can do that. Give me more stuff.
I'll do it more.
Maybe not say that last part because
you got other things to do sometimes,
but I was saying anything you're tasked
with, do it the best you can for,
I mean that even sounds kind of
Cliche, like, Oh, I've heard that,
but to really have that happen,
kind of in your mind where
you regard it all your tasks,
whether you like him or not, that way
where you going to do the best you can it,
then that's a, that's a life
improving situation. Yeah. Yeah,
and going back to what I was taught,
I just thought of this while
you were talking general Mattis,
he said the other day there's an article
about him because he's extremely well
read and he has a personal
library of 7,000 books.
Very smart, very well
educated, very well read.
But what he said is very similar to what
I said. He said, you know, I wouldn't get,
I'm not going to get surprised because
what I'm going to face on the battlefield,
someone else's faced before.
And he made a couple of comparisons.
I can't think of them off the top of
my head, but you know, when I saw this,
when he, you know, he said, when
I saw this for the first time,
I remembered this historical situation.
When I saw that for the first time I
remembered this historical situation.
So I never was surprised by what I was
seeing because I had seen it before,
maybe only in the book,
but at least you have a heads up
and that's what you're looking for.
And what's cool is if you extrapolate
the war,
which is what we're doing on this podcast,
taking the war piece of
it and extrapolating the
human nature piece of it,
and that's going to give you a
broad look at the way people act,
the way humans act and interact.
And that's what I think has been
really good for me to just really,
the other thing is when you,
you know,
when you teach a Jujitsu move and you
get better at it just by teaching it,
if you understand it more well,
for me by writing the notes and putting
them in the podcast and then thinking
about which direction I'm going
to go and warm and talk about,
I've learned it better.
You know,
I've become things that used to things
that I may have known instinctively
before and done for 10 years.
Just like when we wrote extreme ownership,
there was things in there that I said,
you know as well,
I was writing what happened. I'm
like, Oh yeah, I did it here.
I used to do it there.
This is where I learned it,
but I never really thought
about it until and,
and even going beat before that when I
took over the training for the west coast
seal teams, I was the first time
I wrote down the laws of combat,
the four fundamental laws of combat.
Yeah. I had known those. I had,
I had acted that I had
performed them for years.
I had never written them down until I
took over training and saw platoon and
said, these guys aren't doing these things
that would make them successful. Boom.
I wrote them down.
That was it.
And once I wrote them down and sort
of talk about them and show guys,
they made even more sense and I saw them
even easier when people would make a
mistake. So it's, I think it's,
that's what's been good for me is it's
been a real great mental exercise. Yeah.
So thanks everyone for listening and
making me do this podcast once a week,
whether I like it or
not. And actually, yeah.
And that's another thing where,
you know,
we almost went to one
podcast every two weeks. And,
and so I was just talking to a buddy
of mine that's in a company that I was
talking about.
He was at one of the few guys when we,
I kind of was thinking about
this idea of, of, you know,
go into one podcast every two
weeks and we were driving,
his name is Mike and Great Guy, great
leader, and we're driving. And I,
and I said, hey, you know, I'm just,
we were driving to go do some work,
was working with his company. And I said,
you know, I'm thinking about, you know,
maybe doing a podcast once every
two weeks instead of once a week.
And he was driving and I was just the
passenger and, and all of a sudden,
you know, he just Kinda, he
said, hey, you know, I just,
I, I, I don't, I don't think that's
a good idea. And also I was like,
oh my God, you know, and he was really, he
said, look, you know, you can't do that.
You hit a window where we
were listening to the gas,
do we expect it to come out on Wednesday?
It's got to come on a Wednesday.
And then he was like, okay, and he
could compromise the least is, look,
if you're going to do it, then you need
to, you know, you need to give us a warm,
like a six month warning so people
can start to get used to it. And uh,
that was one of the things that
swayed me to say, you know what?
I need to start to keep,
hold the line on the podcast.
That was the other thing. What?
It's hard. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
Hey Jocko, Mr. Sitting around saying,
hey, if it's hard to do it anyways,
and here I was, it was kind of hard, so
I was going to stick it out. No cold.
The line, Jocko, I'm talking to you
Jocko. Practice what you preach.
You know what I mean?
Yeah. It's hard. It's hard.
You got to read a book and you
got to underline takes them. Oh,
so what do it anyways, there
it is. Bring it all right.
It's true.
Mike for the podcast continually coming
out on once a week I think plain,
but it
one of the other things,
kind of like what you're saying
is that going to go is um,
you kind of either do it and get it done.
This personally in my experience,
speak from experience where you know,
you'll ask about about something like,
Hey, what's the status on this or that?
So it's either done or it's
not done where you can be, oh,
you know, I would've done that,
but you know, I did all this stuff,
all that stuff after you
said I would have done that.
But like that doesn't matter at all.
Either you did it or you didn't do
it either. You were like, you know,
Kinda like how lake says you either
effective or ineffective kind of thing.
And the more,
and I think it's has a lot to do with
just hanging around you more where I'd
tell you about something and you'd be
like, okay, is this done or whatever,
or is this about to be done? Or where are
we on this? And then I'll say, oh yeah,
it's done. Then it's like, okay, you have
this kind of look of, okay, like solid,
like thumbs up kind of thing. But if
I say no, not yet because of this,
right when I go into,
because you have this kind of weird haze
that goes over you, like you don't care.
You're nice, you're nice.
Well, and you're not like, Woo,
do you mean you're not like that at all?
But I can see the little haze go over
you like you don't care at all about the
DC excuses that I'm about to say
or these justifications that.
So, and that was early on now
I just know it's automatic.
It's like either the answer is yes or no,
and if it's no and it
should have been done,
then next time I see it should be done.
And that applies to everything.
And I make the analogy where nothing of
the story where my brother would be like,
hey, buy me some wine. I'm like, wine, you
ever been into wine section? It's huge.
It just give me this warning. It's
called this, it's called this, you know,
it's the Cabernet, I dunno,
whatever you call them.
That should be like the
beef jerky section. There's,
that's how big the beef jerky
section. Yeah, Bro. Yeah it
should be. But as of now,
it's wine and if you go in there and he
wants some specific wine and it's easy
to go in there and be like, you know
what? This wine section is too vast.
I'm either going to grab anyway and
I, I see and that's it. Or I'm not,
I'm not going to get it.
Don't task me with this big time.
I'm just going in here
to get some letters.
You got me treasure hunting in the wine
section. And so I'm not gonna do that.
But I had it in my mind. I'm like, no,
you want some wine, you want this one?
All right, well I'm going to get it. Cause
when I come home playing around, yeah,
when I come home, either I got the
wine there, I didn't get the wine.
And you don't want to be the guy who
didn't get the line no matter what your
excuse is.
I'm telling you, Bro,
apply that to everything.
I apply that to something important.
You know? Jade's wine is important.
Unimportant. Jeez. Nonetheless.
Yeah. All good things
we got from this podcast.
I think I would concur.
Next question,
does the,
you know what else is cool about this
podcast is people that the hearing from
people that have done made
some awesome progress.
Yeah, and that's awesome. That's,
that's bad is actually the best thing
about the podcast is hearing from people
out in the field that got promoted,
got a new job,
moved to leadership position,
lost 72 pounds,
gained 12 pounds of lean
muscle mass, you know, w, w, W,
whatever those, whatever the achievement
was. I talked to a guy the other day
that that stopped a biting his nails,
right?
Like you don't think much of it, but
he said he bit his nails for, you know,
34 straight gears and tried the little
nail Polish that goes on there and you
know, you, you go to the hypnotist and
you go to all these different things. No.
And you know when you don't,
when you finally said,
I'm not going to bite my nails anymore,
not going to do it.
I'm going to impose my
will switch to manual.
So here in everybody that does
that kind of thing is awesome.
That's definitely the most that.
So I guess I'm going into not
what I learned about this,
the general overall reward of the podcast
is to talk to people that have made
some significant progress in their life
and they attribute that progress to
listen to podcasts,
which I always re attribute when they
comment about it back to them because I
didn't stop biting your nails at you
did. I didn't lose 72 pounds. You did.
I didn't get promoted. You did. That's
you. That's not me. That's you. Yeah man.
It's,
and so it's cool that you got a little
little little boost.
Sure. From the podcast.
Maybe you saw something a little bit
differently. That's awesome. But you know,
you out there in the field,
you're the one that's making it happen.
We're sitting back here, maybe
providing a little cover, fire,
little cover and move going on. But the,
the thing that's cool about that too is
it's,
it
proves what we talk about
on here all the time,
which is the human will is so strong, but
sometimes people go through their life,
they didn't know that they had it right.
And so they just got to
get recognized that, hey,
you've got this strong will that you can,
you can, you can use. I was, I was,
I was listening to an interview with
Jack Black of tenacious d and he was
talking about when he first discovered
that he had a good singing voice and he
was in high school and he tried out
for some school play and then he was
supposed to sing this part
and he hit that. And when he
did he, he said to himself like,
wow, you know, I've got this
thing, I've got this Lamborghini.
I didn't know I had this. I got this
extra gear that I can kick into.
And that's exactly what he says by the
way, he says, just got this extra gear.
That's what I think
people listen to podcasts.
They all of a sudden realize
I've got this extra gear.
They got this thing and that they didn't
know they had because they never had it
tested before. Never talked about
it. No one ever showed it to them.
They didn't recognize
it for whatever reason.
And then all of a sudden they realize,
oh I got this human will that is stronger
than my weakness and I'm just going to
engage it.
Watch this nail biting.
No more jelly donuts not
happening. Yeah, getting,
getting out worked at work.
Not going to happen.
I think it's the product cause I'm one
of those people straight up where I was
surprised that how much,
how little actual will it took to
make these little changes, you know,
because and, and it's good because
it does like these books and stuff.
It puts it into perspective where these
guys are really exercising their will
with these crazy things. And all that
is is it is an illustration. That's it.
That's it. It didn't even take me
hearing that to understand that,
oh it doesn't take much wheel to do
a workout when I didn't feel like it.
It didn't, it didn't take that
from me to recognize it. That's,
that's just an illustration. It took
me actually doing it and being like,
that wasn't hard at all.
It seems hard.
And here's another reason
why people don't realize it.
I think I was one of those
people who didn't really,
because everywhere you look,
you're always seeing like the,
the four uh,
helpful tips to stop
biting your nails or the,
for all these like external things,
you know,
they go into it to go to a hypnotist,
go do something outside of yourself
kind of thing. Put some nasty tasting,
nail Polish on your fingers so it makes
you not want to buy all this stuff where
really all you have to do just how you
always say, oh you have to do is do it.
You know, you don't, you want
to stop biting your nails. Okay,
stop biting your nails.
And if you really look at it like that,
where like if you would have said to
me, Oh, you don't feel like working out,
go work out. If I would have been
okay, I don't feel like working out so,
so I'm going to go work out and
you just keep it that simple.
That's all you gotta do. Fuck. You'd be
like, Ooh, you're done with the workout.
You're like, Dang, that was easy.
I'm going to do that next time.
You almost kind of look forward to doing
it every once in awhile because I look
forward to exercising your will you
like you get look forward to certain
workouts? Sometimes. Not always.
Right. Sometimes I'm like, oh good,
I got squats today and I don't want to
do it. But sometimes you're like squats.
Yeah, get some so you can get the same
field about about mobilizing your will.
Yeah. It's like that. Yeah, exactly
right. That's exactly what it is.
That's actually one of the reasons I
was listening to a, you know Brady guys,
they have that, the trooper project
podcast, I was just going to one with, um,
with our bill are either our
vulnerable April. I don't know how you,
I just know him. I just know Israel. Yeah.
But I just know him from Twitter. Yeah.
I've never heard his name pronounced,
so I don't know. Savic big beast.
And there were just, they were
talking, um, you know what
music you listened to in
the, in the, you know,
when you work out and
stuff to get nuts and bolt.
I don't listen to any music. And
that's one of the reasons where, oh,
that's why I did it. I was like, Whoa,
I'm always trying to distract
myself from the pain, you know,
and let me listen to this music to get
me fired up or to make me feel good kind
of mentally. And so I can get
through the pain of, you know,
on an old metcons are double or whatever,
just like,
you know what I'm going to do,
listen to no music.
But it turns out I liked that better
now because you just feel more in touch
with like what you're doing. Um, but Oh,
here's, uh, here's one. So I'll do a,
what do they called?
They're kind of like front squats,
but you hold the two kettle
bells like this. They're like,
I forget what they're called,
but um,
so I'll do a 25 reps of 25 so it's hard.
So when you get to about 12,
you're like, aw, you gotta, you know,
you kind of start to hit a certain type
of wall and then when you get up to like
16, 18, you're like, ah, you know,
so what as a result of that, I would
play little numbers, games in my mind.
So I'd count backwards from six, six,
five, four, you know what I mean?
So you just kind of like,
why I'm approaching the end.
It'll be done soon kind of thing. But
what I started doing it like, nope,
I'm going to count them. One,
two, three, four and you'll,
and in the beginning I
started to feel like, Dang,
when I'm getting up to 12 and I'm like,
oh my gosh,
the pain is coming and it
comes and you're like, Dang.
And then instead of
playing more mental games,
like let's just count down
from here. Cause so the end
is, you know, insight, nope,
I'm going to count up now.
And when you count up the numbers going
up give you this weird mental picture.
Like the pain is coming more now cause
you're, you're deeper into this thing.
You know,
and it's like this,
it's almost like mental abuse
you're doing to yourself.
But after awhile you can
look forward to that.
You got to look forward to
those higher numbers. You know,
it's like bring it kind
of thing and it gets you,
it essentially gets you even more
fired up. Yeah, that's good. Oh,
I'm telling you, embrace
the, the pain in her gray.
Does the inability of the average
person to defend themselves,
make them more susceptible
to fear generally in life.
And Can Jujitsu, present
Jujitsu, reduce societal fear?
Have you, is it a pretty
obvious answer? But yeah,
I mean obviously if you
can defend yourself,
it's going to give you more
confidence in the world.
And if you don't know how to dissent,
defend yourself,
you're going to have more fear in
the world. That's just the way it is.
And I know that Jujitsu definitely gave
me a lot of confidence in the world
because when you're
looking at someone you,
you at least know you're not a
pushover at a minimum, you know,
I'm not going to go out easily.
So yeah,
I think if you don't know how
to defend yourself at all,
I think you're definitely going to be,
but more susceptible to fear does.
That's kind of common sense.
And also the the thing with not knowing
when you don't know about things,
you, you are more scared of them.
You wouldn't confrontations cause
you're on the, on the Jitsu, Matt,
you're in competitions all the time.
And if you do an occasion, you know,
occasionally you should put on boxing
gloves and boxing even strike during
Jujitsu or you should do that stuff.
So you recognize what it's like to
be in a fight and then you have,
you'll be less afraid of the
unknown because it's known.
We're always afraid of the unknown.
Well now this is known. Now,
the other thing is,
the better you are with Jujitsu
and the better you are at fighting,
the less apt, the less likely you
are to have to use it. Because,
because people will know that you,
by the way you're acting,
that you're probably not person
that should be messed with.
And the other thing is,
I think when people
actually know how to fight,
they put up less of a
front about who they are,
about trying to act like a tough guy.
Because I ain't man,
I'm feeling pretty good. You know, I
ain't got no problem. Say Hi to you.
I can say hi to you in the street.
Like, hey, how's it going? No big deal.
I'm not feeling like you're going to take
advantage of me now because I know how
to fight. So a lot of Jiu Jitsu
guys are super nice guys, you know,
because they're not trying to prove how
tough they are because you actually know
how tough they are. So I think
that's pretty obvious, you know? Uh,
that's the, the many benefits of
Jujitsu from a personal level.
And then as far as societal
fear, I would also say yes, it's,
it's helpful because if you can handle
yourself on a personal level, right,
then you can handle yourself in other
dynamic situations and you're more aware
of things and you are
better at staying calm.
Reggie Jujitsu teaches you
how to stay calm. Well yeah,
you're getting a bad situation. If
you panic, you're going down. So,
and you get getting put bad
situations all the time.
So you get used to it and you realize
that you needed to attach and you need to
do to get out of your head and can't
panic and can't get claustrophobic.
He used to get claustrophobic and you
don't really get claustrophobic too much
anymore, allegedly straight up. And,
and also with Jujitsu and you know,
mixed martial arts training, boxing, Moy,
Thai wrestling, you overcome adversity.
You know, you overcome
adversity. You have to,
and so when you know how to overcome
adversity on the mat or in the cage or in
the ring, that's going to help you
in real life overcome adversity.
So I think that those are real simple
reasons why just as good if you didn't
think I thought Jujitsu is good.
I do think it's good.
It's good for good for everyone,
right update and really there's a lot
of martial arts you could put in there.
I'm talking about Jiu Jitsu,
but it's the same with boxing.
It's the same with with Muay Thai.
It's the same with wrestling.
It's the same with judo. Sometimes I
forget to mention judo, I shouldn't.
Judo is also very effective martial art,
so I think all those things
are very helpful for personal,
overcoming personal fear and giving
people confidence and their thereby
overcoming societal
fears as well. Yeah, it's kind
of a side note with with the,
with Jujitsu forth,
let's say in this more applies to this
concept kind of has been coming up
recently where you know your
first danger get to where you,
I think you and me and kind of
our time where we started,
you just see we didn't look at it
in terms of like planning guard.
I didn't even know you started Jujitsu
in 1992 I'm just saying from 92 all the
way to about, I don't know,
I don't know the date,
but I'm saying if you like old school
Jujitsu where use partly started unit two
because of hoists. Gracie, if you're
one of these people, one of us.
That's why I started just doing hoists.
Gracie won UFC one,
you know where we looked at Jujitsu as,
okay,
if I get in a fight with someone I
want to be able to win the fight.
Even if he's bigger than me.
It wasn't because,
oh I want to be the next world champion,
you know,
concerned about how to effectively hold,
you know, the most points on buddy. Yeah.
Or when I pulled guard, like the coolest
like flip move, I can do it, whatever.
And I'm not saying like that's
what it is and I'm not saying that,
but there that is in the game now.
So sometimes as a result of this,
sometimes you can go with no Jujitsu
experience. You don't know about twice,
Gracie necessarily. You haven't, you know,
that isn't what compelled you to learn
Jujitsu. You just hear great things like,
you know, from Dako or whoever and you're
like, Hey, I want to go learn Jujitsu.
This is the best fighting thing
according to Jack. I'm going to go see,
I'm going to go see what up.
And then they go in there and then let's
say the first day they'll learn, um,
you know, just an arm lock
from the bottom or you know,
something that if you don't go in with
the full context of what Jujitsu is,
it won't translate. You know, you, you'll
learn a move and you'd be like, wait,
how am I going to go in a fight now? You
know, it's like, cool, that's a cool move.
It's kind of like, you know what guy?
Hey, let me show you when you're a kid,
let me show you this finger lock.
And you're like, that's cool,
but how are you going to get my
finger? Yeah, exactly. You know,
like all this stuff just
doesn't apply to US fight. So,
so just to answer your question,
I just did a little like tiny, uh,
instructional thing for some people
that hadn't trained before and it was a
support, a charity. And so
it's all good. But you know,
these people never done [inaudible]
before and I taught them, you know,
the amount escape, right. And
immediately, you know, one of the guys,
hey, you know what happens when they do
this because he's doing this right here.
Yup. Okay. So bring it back in
everyone. And it basically, you know,
after this happened a couple times I said,
here's the deal.
I'm teaching you a new language.
Yeah.
So far I've taught you the
word thug. Right? Right.
That's the only word I've taught you
thought. Yeah. I haven't even taught you.
I cause that would,
that would be a context of self awareness,
which you don't have. We don't have,
you only know VA. That's it. That's it.
That's all you know. And
actually I shouldn't have
been you. I should have said,
I just talked to you.
The word purple. Yeah.
Because you can't though actually
can apply to different things. Right.
This when you just learn one
thing, it's, it's not meaningless,
but it's only, it's almost like
if walk into a foreign country
and the only word you knew
how to say was purple. Yeah.
And their language, it's not going to get
you very far at all. Right? It's not. No.
And that's the same thing.
So you're right in the context
of like a singular move.
Jujitsu is worthless right now.
Backburnered when I learned five moves
and knew of the rear naked, choke the arm,
walk the Camino and no
one else knew anything.
W when you can say five different words
in a world where no one can speak,
you have power.
And that's the way it used to be and how
it's not like that anymore. Everybody,
everybody watches UFC. Everybody
watches UFC. And so the,
everyone's seen an arm lock before.
Everyone's seen a rear naked choke.
They didn't. You can watch a rear naked
choke and see that's a simple move.
You can see how you put that on somebody.
So yes you are correct.
But if you got it,
you got to do more than just the
context of like a singular move.
Cause that's what I'm going
to be very useful to you.
Yeah. So when you, um, all right,
I remember watching you a fee and there
was a guy who had commentate, right?
Kind of a nerdy guy, but
he, he kind of knew a,
apparently he took Jujitsu so he would
kind of call it, he'd be like, okay,
so now who crazy. He wants to get
on top right now, stop his position.
He can't give to take down. So now he's
pulling guard kind of thing and then,
or he'll be like, okay, he's establishing
position with a mouse and he's going to,
he's going to punch him until he turns
over and then he's going to choke him and
he's calling it any does it.
Right. So I remember thinking,
okay that mount position,
very, very powerful.
Or if he's on the bottom, you want guard
kind of thing, you can see, you know,
cause he kind of explained.
So when I first started
Jujitsu, like an actual class,
I knew what guard was.
I knew what mount was.
I knew those positions and why they're
important, where you know, like if you're,
if someone's mounted on you were hoists,
Gracie would always be
mounted on the person.
It's like it's really hard to get out.
He's going to struggle and end if you
turn over your even worst situation,
you know?
So I kinda knew that.
So I knew the actual context and a lot
of people when they go into just to just
because they hear about how cool
it is, they don't have that, that,
that foundation going in. So
I think, man, I think that,
I dunno if they'd ask for it or what.
But I think when, when, when instructors,
when a new person, a brand new person
don't know these zero days of Jujitsu,
if they teach that like this
is the amount, this is why
it's important, you know,
just like how you did at the muster
where you're like, you know, I can hit,
you can hit just like that.
And then that'll provide content.
And then at the end how you taught a move
submission or whatever. Then it's like,
okay, in this is one of the many
things you can do. And it's like, oh,
and by the way, when I say many
infinite, yes, yes, yes. Yeah. So yeah,
I think that if you,
and I guess this goes out to like anyone
who goes into their Jujitsu class and
learned,
it just happened to be on the day where
you learn like some kind of arbitrary
move. Given the fact that you don't know
the foundation it with the foundation,
any move is going to make a lot more
sense as long as you have that foundation
and the importance of the importance
of guard that worked until you know all
these other things. Of course we all want
to learn the submission. What's cool,
the mission,
who can I get
this guy in? Who wants to fight this guy?
Yeah. Another thing that people ask is,
you know, will he keeps pulling
my hand away. I go, yeah,
it's a fight fighting another person.
It's not just who's not magic. I saved.
You did some magic, but it's not magic.
It's not magic. It's an actual fight.
The person is going to resist.
You have to have moves. I didn't,
it doesn't turn into magic
until you have it all together.
Then that turns into magic and then
you bestow it upon someone who does it.
You know? It is like magic man.
He's this little guy, George,
he's a purple belt and I
was white belt and man he's,
he's the one who taught me butterfly
guard. He was small too. And he would,
he'd be flying me around doing butterfly
guard sweeps and like straight arm
locks and stuff like from the bottom like,
Bro, what is this guy doing? Magic. Yeah.
And one time he's like
someone out while we're,
you know how like when you're rolling
you can kind of talk to people while
you're rolling.
You know,
especially if you're rolling with
a guy who has advanced as well,
because you don't have to focus on
what you're doing kind of thing.
So this was an introduction of that
concept where I'm rolling with George,
he's carrying on a conversation with
his inappropriate. Do those weekend.
It wasn't that it was someone was
asking him like, Hey, like how do you,
how did you do that kind of thing.
He was like,
well this is what he's doing and while
we're rolling he's kind of commentating
his rolling and he's like, so,
and this sets up the suite,
which I'm about to get them with an it
and he gets me with the sweep and well
that's the small,
that's why it is.
That's why it is kind of magic magic
because if I could make this coin
disappear, if I could actually do
that, that would be magic. Yeah.
If I can take your arm against your
will and straighten it out and there's
nothing you can do to stop it.
Yeah. It's kind of magic is to
say, I mean that is what
magic is though. Right?
When when you make make it here, it's
like illusion. Right. Were you a makeup?
I'm not talking about, I'm talking
about actual, yeah. Actual magic. Yeah.
No such thing.
But it does seem that way when they don't
know when they don't know how you did
that. Again, he had it, you know
what I mean? Like similar to that,
making the coin disappear,
but it really just went behind knuckle
or whatever possible you buy 50 pounds.
Let me see how you did that.
Yeah, watch this. Do it again.
Do it again. Do it to me.
Get it to the
next question.
Hi Jocko.
I've been listening to your,
to you ever since I first
heard you with Tim Ferris.
I've been considering
Jujitsu. Same thing. Yeah.
Ever since hearing you guys talk
about it so passionately, however,
I've had a shoulder. I've
had sold shoulder surgery,
liberal tear in the past,
and some issues with bicep tendinitis
and I'm worried that grappling sport,
that grappling support might
make me prone to injury. Again,
would you recommend Jujitsu
for someone like me?
Thanks in advance for taking the
time and providing your headlight.
So there's another form of Jujitsu,
actually a
that I don't talk about very much,
but it's definitely a feasible
thing for a situation like this.
And that's the learning Jujitsu,
right? Learning, Jujitsu,
learning the moves,
drilling them,
gaining the understanding of how they all
fit together and then only sparring in
like a really controlled environment.
And by that I mean highly
skilled instructor that isn't
going to hurt you or let
you get hurt doing something stupid
and that will provide you with enough
resistance so that you know,
moves are going to work but not taking
it to fall on level 27 you know,
blood bath battle.
And unfortunately this situation
is kind of is very likely,
and I've seen this before,
I'm sure you have too,
where you get somebody that maybe
they had an injury or maybe there are,
they are in some job where they can't
get hurt, you know? Oh, right, right.
And surgeon or an older
person that doesn't want to
get hurt because they're in
the middle. So I've seen
this, people do this before.
What they do is they
basically take Jujitsu,
they take private Jujitsu classes and may
only role with the instructor and they
learn moves and they learn
how to put together. That's,
that's one way to do it is
you just find a good, now you,
I've heard nightmare
stories about this too,
where the Jujitsu instructor
feels the need to prove himself,
which is just pathetic.
There's no way.
When you go in and you tell them
instructor, Hey, I've got a bad shoulder,
I've got a bad knee, I've got a bad
neck, I've got a bad back. Whatever.
You tell them and you
say, look, I just want it.
I just want to learn the techniques and,
and,
and learn how to apply them in a very
fundamental way. I'm not here to compete.
I have no ego and I don't
want to prove anything.
I just want to be more knowledgeable.
The Gi,
Jujitsu instructor should be more than
happy to take you on board and, and,
and let this, you know, do this.
You can also do it if you,
I mean,
cause Jujitsu private
instruction is very expensive.
You can also do it in a group setting,
but what you have to do is you have to
keep your ego completely in check unlike
anything you've ever tried before.
Because every idiot, and by every idiot,
I mean every human being on earth,
all of them.
You take that person.
If I take a person that weighs 145 pounds,
who's never trained any Jujitsu
or wrestling before, and I say,
okay, you know, you want me
to teach you to, to here,
I'm going to put this arm lock on you
and I take their arm and I say, okay,
so this is what it feels like when you
get arm unlocked. Their instinct is, well,
how are you going to get my arm there?
You won't be able to do that.
And they're gonna fight it. They're going
to fight it, always going to fight it.
So everyone's ego gets involved.
So you have to just completely put your
ego in check because you think, oh,
I'm going to roll with this guy over here,
but I'm have to come a little bit
stronger than we'll cover and you just get
hurt. That's how you get
hurt now, especially if you
have preexisting injuries.
So you have to do that.
You have to find the right
training partners that are
completely mellow and have
nothing to prove and are very relaxed and,
and experienced in Jujitsu.
So if they do catch something that's
going to be a little bit awkward.
Oh yeah man, I'll just let you go. No
big deal, no big deal at all. And, and,
and you do that and then you slowly,
very slowly escalate over time.
Once you know and understand Jujitsu,
you start to go a little bit harder still
keeping your ego in check and all that.
Now if you do that,
you should be able to get
into Jujitsu over Amada. Dr,
I don't know the condition
of your label tear,
so I don't have the authority or the,
or the what,
the proper credentials,
credentials to,
to give you the go ahead.
But if you do what I just said,
there's, you should be. Okay.
Now the problem is that it's
hard to do what I just said.
It's hard for everybody cause everybody's
competitive and Jujitsu's a very
competitive thing. And when I say
competitive, it's mentally competitive.
It just makes you think,
I want to know, want to,
I have these guys in the other
day, these guys are, you know,
the senior executives learning Jujitsu
for the first time, didn't know anything.
And I taught them, you know how I taught
him the open, the elbows scape to,
to escape them out.
I told them to go through them like
just to practice the move on each other.
They do,
they do for six minutes of it,
they come back or calling back in the
middle of there sweating. And you know,
some of the pairs are sweating because
they were having a level seven battle and
those,
and these were again 45 50 55
year old executive type people.
But you try and teach them to move
and they want to fight, you know,
so that's what you got to be careful
of and you know, you don't want to get,
you know, you don't want to worse your
injuries, you don't want to do other,
you want to have other sports impacted.
You know,
you might enjoy surfing or
whatever playing another sport,
basketball and you ruin it and now
you can't play cause you did Jujitsu.
I don't want that to happen to you,
but you can do Jiu Jitsu in a controlled
way that you shouldn't need to get hurt,
but you need to keep your
damn ego in check. Great.
Yeah. And another thing that
that seems obvious I think,
but apparently is not as obvious. Like you
know how you have, you know, labels are,
especially if you had
surgery, I've had said, yeah,
if you had surgery and bicep tendinitis
and these are all things that like if
you do a,
yeah,
okay you got to do a separate
program but you do Rehab,
you'll improve that we're, and that's
really the main thing with these injuries.
You know how people will there have back
or their shoulder stuff that they get
surgery, they get it fixed and
then, but it's still, you know what,
you're just going to have that for the
rest of your life kind of thing. Bro.
If you focus on rehab,
like it's a straight up workout where,
I mean don't push it because
that's not what rehab is, rehab it.
But you focus on that. Like it's an
actual program. Like I've workout program,
take it seriously. Um, but you can,
a lot of times you can get
rid of these things fully.
Especially like a tendonitis,
bicep tendon. I like,
I had surgery on my bicep straight up,
torn off the bone surgery.
So of course I'm going to
be prone to tendinitis.
But you just mean you've got to treat it
like it's like that's another thing of
your body that you got to develop, you
know. Got Folks not tendinitis, you know.
So man,
I would recommend that big time where,
and you'll be more compelled to do it.
When you find a,
how fun did you do to is
and you're like shoot,
I could be getting after it rolling way
better if my shoulder like just felt
better.
And then you go do some extra stuff,
like all these little rotator movements
for your shoulder cause it's shoulder to
sarge. Like during the
demonstration, you know,
starting to gets nuts sometimes doing
a demonstration pulls my shoulder out,
which was kind of hurt from like the
day before from remember Ryan Gillespie?
Oh yeah. Yeah. So he hurt my shoulder
than sarge heard it the next day. Anyway,
so let's Jack couldn't
do any pressing whatever,
do those little bent like you
use those rubber band things. Uh,
and I would use the cables at
the gym at 24 fitness and men,
it brings it back and tendonitis,
same thing.
You can get therapy and stuff like that.
Do that men and it'll help it.
So if you didn't do any kind of rehab
and then you just jump into Jujitsu,
it's like, yeah, you're going to be way
more prone. And you know the, the, the
disclaimer here is like,
it's Jujitsu,
it's a contact sport and
you're going to get twisted up.
And if you're scared of getting
twisted up and you are a,
you know,
concert pianist or you're a surgeon,
you need to accept the
fact that this is the,
this is a full contact sport and you
can definitely get hurt, you know,
and we have, we have, we have
an actual surgery and you know,
we've got several doctors,
but we have an actual
hand surgeon and you know,
Doctor Luke trains [inaudible] Nogi does
it all full speed and full all the time.
Black belt by the way. Yeah. Black belt by
the way. MMA fighter too. But, but yeah,
he knows the risks. He's cautious.
He takes his finger, you know,
he just take the precautions,
you take the precautions and then you
accept that there is a level of risk.
You know,
I trained for 20 whatever,
five years and I hurt my
finger, you know, like whatever.
A couple of weeks ago. Dang. And I
just heard another finger, they don't,
these things happen.
So what are you going to do?
You're going to not train. That's
a, that's a, that's a possible,
it's kind of an option I guess.
Yeah. It's kind of an option,
but you can train in a method that you
are a lot less likely to get hurt and you
can go so far in the spectrum
of not getting hurt that you,
that you could really get that possibly
getting hurt to an absolute minimum.
And that's what I say.
If you're training with a black belt
instructor and you're just doing privates
and you guys have a
really good understanding,
your chance of getting hurt
a pretty small, yeah, yeah.
But yeah, if you, if you let
that keep you from doing it,
I think you're doing
yourself more harm than good.
And that goes for anything really.
It's like Dang,
if have to go to the post office,
but you're scared of the statistics
of car crashes and you can,
so we can do not go to the post office.
Right? You got to mail that thing,
you know,
you got to get it done.
True. Next question. You've got to mail
that thing. I go or whatever. You know,
whatever the case may be.
When you're stepping into a leadership
role and you have someone on your staff
who's not a team player,
creates clicks goes over me and straight
to my bosses when there's a problem and
whenever he went,
whenever has concerns voices them
among teammates and not directly to me.
How do I continue in my role?
How do I assess myself
and how do I tackle this?
Biggest thing we got to do is build in a
relationship with that person. You know,
you got to get in that person's head,
you got to find out what's going on,
you got to find out, you
gotta, you gotta talk to him.
You got to build that relationship.
You got to talk to him about why
they're going over your head. You then,
then you know what?
When they say,
well I'm going over your head because this
happens. You Go, oh, I didn't know that.
You don't,
I'm going to get that fixed.
And you build up a little trust and
then they say some other problems.
You get that one fixed and then you
say, hey man, you know it's, you know,
it's kind of hurts the team is when
you're telling the team things that are
negative and if we could work together to,
you know,
you tell me what's going on, it's
negative and then we solved the problem.
We're going to do better as a team.
And that's,
that's my goal is just
to do better as a team.
And I see that you're a leader because
people listened to you and when you start
saying negative things,
they start thinking negatively cause
you just influential person and, and I,
and the influence you have over people,
something that is going to be,
can be very beneficial to what
we're doing. If you want it to be,
I want you to want it to be, but you
know, I'm not you. You have that I don't.
So let's work.
If you could help me move this in a
positive direction so our team can be more
successful. That's the kind
of thing I would do here. And,
and the other thing is, you
know, ask them straight up, hey,
what am I doing wrong as leader? What
can I do better? Where can I become?
Where can I make more things happen?
So that way and what you're doing
is you're letting down your guard,
you're letting them give
him the opportunity to
hopefully be honest with you
about what you're doing wrong. And
then you can give them, you know,
you can correct those measures.
Now there is a possibility that this
person is jerk. And when you say,
what am I doing wrong?
They go back and say, hey,
this guys even know what he's doing.
He's just so,
that's why you need to take it slowly
and feel the situation out in and make an
assessment of how they're going to react
to these things and build a little bit
of a little bit of leadership capital
with that person before you go and say,
Hey, what am I screwing up?
Because then it's like, Yo, dude,
Jocko doesn't even know what he's doing.
He's asking me what he should be doing.
So don't, if the person is a jerk,
you have to watch out for that.
So that's what we're going to
build a relationship first.
It's like building a relationship
seems like a very common theme,
far stretching solution. It
is very much so. Uh, you know,
you take the extreme example of I'm a
hostage taker and you're my hostage and
I'm threatening to kill you.
What are you supposed to do?
Build a relationship with me.
You want to get me to see you as a human.
That's what we're talking about. The
same thing. That's an extreme example,
but this is the same thing going on here.
It's a really dumped,
by the way I heard this with story on
the news, I forget how old the girl was.
He was a kid though,
a girl kid and she'd,
all she did was Blab to this guy who
kidnapped her and he wound up letting her
go. There you go. Cause she,
she built that relationship with this
team member that's creating clicks and
doing all this negative stuff. It's
because he doesn't know you, you know?
And he's, he's just going, I don't know.
You know, chocolate is a mystery to me.
He doesn't hang out. I don't
know. I ease, he's bad. Don't die.
He just v there's a separation. Yeah.
So I'm going to close that separation.
I'm going to Blab to them.
I'm going to build a relationship and
we're gonna let that little kid go. Yeah,
yeah.
I remember
the nightclub where, you know, you have
different bosses, different managers,
they work different shifts or whatever.
So one guy,
his name is Matt Gilmore, tall, tall
guy. I love that guy. He was a real,
I don't know, for whatever. He's like,
I should, I could just relate to him.
You know,
he was just real nice and I don't,
another way he talked was kinda not
funny like a comedian, but just kind of,
you know, some people when they talk
it's just kind of entertaining, you know,
every time,
every once in a while they'll use certain
words that's just kind of unique to
them. It's like, oh, I like that. Anyway,
really liked him. And so I was hoping,
and he would usually work on
Friday, Saturdays, right? He was,
he was kind of high up.
And then there's other guy,
I'm not going to say his name nonetheless.
There's this other guy and this guy,
he was like the full on kind where
he had this air about them where he,
I'm the manager of this
club kind of thing.
And on off times if he'd be at like a
party or something that we were cruising
or whatever and he'd talk
about how, yeah, you know,
I'm in the office doing
these sexual things with this
person and just, you know,
real, real douchey for lack of better
term, real douchey kind of guy.
And one time he was, um, there was
this rule lawn as long time ago.
There's this rule,
you can't go upstairs.
There was like three levels in this club,
so you can't go upstairs.
It's like this high end kind of lounge.
You can't wear jeans upstairs.
There's a dress code. I had
been to that. Yeah, no, no.
You would not be welcome for
flops and shorts or no, no.
You won't even get in the
front though apparently. Um,
so one day on my off night I had jeans on.
I went upstairs real quick just to talk
to one of my friends cake nuts and cause
he was up there and so was talking
to him and this guy, this manager,
that one I didn't like, he was up there
and he'd be like, he was like, Hey,
the rules apply to everyone, you know,
go downstairs. So I'm like, ah, you know,
I'm just, I will, I'm just going
to talk to him. And he's like,
the rules apply to everyone. Go
downstairs like not be nice about it off.
I'm like, all right, whatever. That's
just an example of one experience.
The next week he comes in on his night
genes upstairs or whatever and as a joke,
not being a dick as a joke, I was like,
hey, you have jeans on. I was working.
And he's like, he goes, he's all, yeah,
well my title has a bit more
letters than yours does.
That's what he said to me.
So
I'm not sure where we're going with this.
I know that I was gonna say that's an
example of him not building a relationship
with me.
Matt Gilmer wouldn't have said that.
No,
he would us either not,
he would either compromised with me
the first night or he would have,
he would have laughed at my
joke and be like, ha ha, good
point. Whatever. Or both.
He probably would have done both.
Still friends with Matt Gilbert by
the way. Um, okay. Next question.
In light of recent events,
what is the best course of action
when confronted by an obvious abusive
authority resulting in personal injury
due to an innocent person to an innocent
person. Oh, tune in to an innocent person
that that occurs in one's presence.
At what point is it acceptable to
physically engage with the assailant even
though the assailant has some
kind of authority? Sorry,
that's two questions. What,
what's the, um, recent
event event? Is the,
the person on the airplane getting
dragged off an insured because the,
it was over. Yeah.
Yeah. Overbooked flight.
So W,
n you know,
obviously I guess you could put more
recent events is you know, if you,
if you could have a police
officer that's doing something,
you could have a bouncer.
You know,
I'm sure you have plenty of stories
about your night club days besides just
wearing jeans in the wrong area,
which you know, has a big violation.
But so, so here's what, here's what,
here's my answer to this. What do you do?
You're one of those things happen.
First of all,
the people that are in the situation are
wrapped up in the situation. They're,
they're emotionally,
mentally wrapped up in a situation
to situation has escalated.
They're caught in a storm
and you're not in the storm.
You're outside the storm.
So what do most people do?
And they see that storm going on. What
do most people do? Tell me. Panic. No,
they pull out their I phones and
they start recording situation.
That's what they do. That's what everyone
does. Hey, oh, there's a fight going on.
Worldstar let's do you
know what I'm saying?
I'm impressed that you know about world.
Well,
they have a lot of good fights on
there, which you have to watch. So yeah.
Well cause you learn from,
you see the way people act,
you see some human nature in, in
videos. So that's what people do.
So what you actually want to do instead
of pulling out your video is you want to
try and get them out of that moment.
Emotionally.
You want to talk to them like a normal
person, engage with them. You know, hey,
hey sir, you need to calm down.
That's just a police officer.
He doesn't mean any harm. Hey, hey,
you know officer that that guy's not
a threat to you. Right. You know,
just take a step back. It looks
like he's trying to relax. You know,
you want to talk them,
disengage them,
getting their heads out of
those bad scenarios. Yeah.
And you'll be in a calm voice. Say some
things, like I said, say something.
Hey officer, there's a lot of people that
are videoing this right now. You know,
just a lot of people saw what
happened. So let's, it's, it's,
you don't have to do anything else.
Let's,
let's get this person under control. I
can give you a hand or whatever, you know,
you just want to you and,
and of course, what are the,
what is their initial reaction to be back
at you but just back away or you don't
shut up your, you know, you
don't know. And, and so you
need to absorb that, right?
Say, Hey, look, I'm not, I'm not
giving you any threats at all.
I'm just here to help out.
I don't want to see any trouble.
Don't want you to get in trouble.
You just want to talk to people and get
them to get them out of that emotional
storm that they're in both sides,
both sides,
because it's a really nasty situation.
You know, when you don't listen to me,
when I start to hurt you, when
I grabbed your, your risk,
let's say like one of those like, uh,
police pain, compliance type moves,
I grabbed your wrist and I start
to twist it. You as a human being,
the natural instinct it, some people
might have the instinct to comply,
but a lot of people have the instinct
of you grabbed me and start hurting me,
I'm going to pull away. Okay, you're
resisting now you're resisting.
So what I need to do,
I need to go harder with a harder I go,
the more you resist and you
see where this is going.
Next thing you know I'm beating you in
the head cause I don't know how to use a
show called unfortunately because in
some areas choke holds are illegal.
So again, as the outsider, you
want to pull them out of that.
You want to talk to them,
you want to get them to see that outside
of the emotional storm that they're in
both sides.
Both sides are an emotional storm,
physical intervention, you know, now we
are talking like this is a serious step.
You start stepping into these
scenarios. You don't, you know,
you want to be very,
very careful about stepping into
these one of these situations.
And even that physical
escalation should be,
or physical intervention should
be just with the sole purpose of,
of deescalating, right? You're not
walking over and grabbing a guy know,
hey, you know, it's like a hand on the
shoulder. Hey Sir a officer, hey you know,
TSA agent or whoever you are,
hey let's just calm down.
You want me to give you a hand getting
this person under control. You know,
you don't want to get these people to
where now you become because as soon as
you do that you just ended a storm.
You part of the storm.
Now even though you're trying not to be,
you're, you're, you're entering the storm.
So you got to be very, very cautious
about what you're doing there.
And you know,
what would I do in a situation where
I saw someone getting beat to death,
you know, I'm going to
do what I said, you know,
now might I go a little bit further cause
I have a lot of experience and maybe I
can handle this situation. And deescalated
physically. Yeah. And you know,
you see this sometimes where something
we escalating an innocent civilians will
come and help, uh, on officer
secure person. So those,
there's ways to do it. You just gotta be
very, very cautious when you do those,
when you do that. Because the other piece
of this is in any, again, you see us on,
on Youtube, you don't know what
happened to get to this point.
You don't know who that person
is, who the perpetrator is, right.
The perpetrator might look
totally innocent but you
don't know any background.
So when you start stepping in there,
you might be stepping in there to defend
a person that just shot a person or a
person that just,
you know,
got caught doing something or a person
that really did resist the cops hard and
do, do some damage. So
I don't, I don't know.
And I'm generally going to side with
a, with a police officer, right?
I mean the police officer,
I'm, I'm respecting that they,
that they're doing the right thing and
sort of step in there and start making
something happen is not going to
generally work out in a good way. Um,
maybe you can help them get
the perpetrator under control,
but um, yeah. To,
to make the assumption that because a
cop has escalated to a point of violence
that the cop is an out of control. Crazy
cop. It's, but not an accurate assumption.
Most likely. That's the wrong
assumption. Yeah. You know,
cops are not walking around waiting
to, to, to beat the crap out of people.
That's not what they're doing. They
don't want to do that when it happens.
It's something,
something has generally led up to it.
When we see it in a case
that isn't like that.
That's why we see it because
it's now news is now news. Yeah.
So be very, very careful
about that. Again, you know,
most of the time, you know, just
try and deescalate it verbally.
Ask if they need any assistance.
Ask if you can call nine one one form
and get more assistance for them.
Ask if they need any help, talk to them,
you know, do that, take that approach.
If you have to physically intervene,
especially if you have some experience,
you know, let them know what
you're doing. Do you need any help?
Do you need any assistance?
That type of thing.
And I'm sure we'll get some feedback from,
from some cops on this one
and it'll be good. Yeah. Yeah.
I feel it when I was back to the balance,
her situation when guys would,
you know,
a fight would break out.
So in a club when a fight break breaks
out is more chaotic than, you know,
in the street when you
see two guys fighting.
So it's a little bit more dangerous when
you jump into the fight to try to break
it up. Because if you just
jump in and grab the guy,
the guy doesn't know if you're trying
to break up the fight or if you're for
sure you're just another
attacker. Yeah, exactly right.
So he's gonna start swinging or whatever.
Um,
and that's not to mention any of that
guy's friends who sees you do that in the
dark. You know all this, you know,
the dark nightclub lights, whatever.
So he might hit you, whatever. And
then, you know, bottles can be,
it can be dangerous.
So if you jump in there with,
before you even touch the person,
you, you're already saying break it.
What I would always say is either break
it up or, or calm down. I calm down guys,
break it up, break it up before you
even touch them. And they hear that.
So when they feel you, they don't feel
a punched. Got It. It's like calm down,
calm down, and they feel you kind
of, it's more of a light given, uh,
compared to the, the guy who he's
fighting with. Is that a punch?
It's not a wrestling moves,
nothing like that.
It's like you're breaking it up and
you just gave me a good reminder too.
If you're on the outside and you
see something like this going on,
like if you're on that plane,
you see this, this, uh,
this passenger getting roughed
up. Hey, hey, hey passenger.
Just calm down. Do what they're
telling you to do. Just do what?
They're just comply with what they're
doing to do, you know, just relax.
Let them cough. You just relax. You
know, you can take, uh, you know,
I definitely heard a
cop say this actually,
I heard the guy that was
on Sam Harris podcasts.
Like if you want to got an issue with what
a cops doing to bring it to the court,
let your lawyers handle it.
Don't handle it right there
because you're going to lose,
you're going to lose that situation.
You're going to end up hurt.
You're gonna end up injured. It's gonna
be a bad scenario. Yeah. So same thing.
Tell them, tell, you know,
if you see someone getting,
getting roughed up, then hey,
hey man, we're all watching. Just comply.
Just do what they're telling you to
do and take it up with a lawyer later.
Just try and get that person to calm
down. Cause that's, you know, chances are,
you know, the police
officer, he's arrested,
thousands of people put his
hands on thousands of people.
That person that's getting roughed up,
they haven't, they've not been arrested.
I can guarantee you that the United
passenger probably never been arrested in
his life. So here he is. And like
I said, you start to pull me,
I'm going to resist. I don't want people
don't pull me know, but don't pull me.
But now all of a sudden we got an incident
going on. So if someone's saying, hey,
listen, just listen to what they're
telling you. You need to just calm down.
You don't want this to get any worse.
That type of thing.
Talk to people and get them
to detach a little bit.
And obviously the United situation isn't,
isn't this real linear
situation where it's like, hey,
that's the passenger's fault. He should've
just went with them. Kind of. I mean,
there's honestly all I know about,
I don't know anything about it other
than I saw the guy getting dragged out of
the plant.
That's what,
that's the only part I saw a guy getting
dragged out of the plane and I saw the
good Gracie Gracie
breakdown of out of habit.
How to defend yourself in that situation.
Yeah. And uh, he was, uh, he was,
it's just a long story. Who's there
was that does apply, you know,
if you're getting arrested or, or,
or taken off the plane or whatever,
and you choose to fight for your
rights right then and there, the amen.
That's a battle that you're going
to, you got to do that, you know,
and there's consequences to that. When
you mean you got to do that. It's like,
can you give her the expression?
If you want to be a gangster,
you got to do gangster stuff. Okay. It's
actually a gangster shit, but, but, but,
but you're not, you're not advising.
I'm saying if you want that beef,
then you're going to get that.
Yeah. So, so yeah. Do it.
But like I said,
especially with like the cops,
if they're arresting you and you're
like, hey, you violated my rights,
so I'm going to fight you
right now for my rights. Yeah.
If you want that beef, okay.
But it's, you're going to be more,
you're gonna be safer, first off,
and more effective if you fight for your
rights administratively later. Yeah. And,
um, so nonetheless, a kind of
on a tangent there, but um,
the, Oh, the Co, uh, when you're
helping the cops or whatever,
it's the same way as if you're a bouncer.
You kind of identify
yourself kind of thing.
Just like how you were saying
and it is easy I think to,
and they call it availability
bias, right? It's easy to be like,
all of these cops are beating this guy up.
And I see this on youtube all the time
where the cops just beat up these guys,
you know,
so these are bad cops or whatever.
But it's like anything where when you
say how you say it made the news because
it's this bad cop situation,
it's in your mind, you know,
all the good cops and like legit RF,
all that.
They're not on your new millions if
they're not on youtube. Yeah, exactly.
And even if they were,
that doesn't stick in your mind.
Lady views businesses.
Usually
the video of a police officer
doing his job. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
No one wants to watch that.
They want to see somebody screwing up
and they forget about it. It's totally not
in their mind. So yeah, anything screw,
you know,
being screwed up or anything that just
has this emotional impact on their mind,
they're going to think he's like
way more common than it really is.
So I think it's important to
kind of keep that in mind always.
Absolutely.
Next question,
if you have a subordinate that hasn't
improved after talks and instruction but
can't, but you can't fire
them because of the union,
what do you do?
I'm going to find something that they're
good at and I'm going to get them to
focus on that. And um,
you know, as a leader,
that's what you're trying to do as a
leader. You got to make your team members,
if you've got team members that you,
that you can't get rid
of for whatever reason,
and they're not quite doing
what they should be doing,
or they're not up to speed, what can they
do? What can they offer to the theme?
When I find out what you
can offer to the team,
I'm going to have you focus on
that. It's the way it is. If there,
if that causes some kind of disruption.
Because you know,
echo can only move 10 bricks a day and
everyone else is moving 200 and so now
everyone's all mad cause echo is not
working, not carrying his load. Well,
I'm in a, you know, well number one,
I'm gonna look for a job for him where
he's no one sees him carrying not
carrying bricks, right?
Hey, instead of doing that,
you're going to organize the bricks
over here. You're going to count,
you're going to count
Brex cause your week.
So you're going to be the brick counter.
So that's what gonna do.
I'm just going to change it up and to
find out what they can do. That's what,
that's what you have to do as leader.
And by the way,
I'm not going to give up on them. I might
not, I might not invest a ton of time,
but I'm gonna keep saying, hey, you know,
if you want to move from
counting bricks to move and is,
which got to do and here's what you
gotta do, you gotta keep working.
You've got to keep getting stronger to
work on your dead lift work when you know,
get a little bit stronger so you can
carry more bricks. So it's, you know,
when that happens,
it doesn't just happen because of unions.
It happens for all different of that.
In the military you can't,
you get a guy that he's
in a situation where,
yeah, he's not going to get, we're not
going to let him go. Yeah. You know,
we've got to keep x amount
of people in country. Okay,
so this guy's one of the people in
country we were not allowed to get rid of.
Okay, cool. Well what can you
do? Maybe you can count bricks.
They know what happened. Can, would
be the best brick counter we got.
Yeah.
You might have to do a little
isolation too. You know what I mean?
You might have to isolate them a little
bit again because you don't want people
thinking, Oh, echoes over there, you know,
in the air condition and he doesn't do,
do and carry his load and so that can
cause problems. Yeah. And chocolate.
Just letting it happen because I
was letting it happen, you know?
So you might have, you got to,
you got to figure this out.
How do you isolate them a little bit?
How you make sure that they're working,
you know, maybe you can only count
brexitpreneur of you working more hours,
you know,
or doing some other thing to make up
for your slack in the brick clearing
category.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Bottom line,
as a leader,
when you get somebody that doesn't quite
do what they need to do and you can't
get rid of them, find out what they
can do and take advantage of it,
using it to the best of
their ability for supporting
deep. It kind of seems like, I
mean given what you just said that,
I mean this might dumb it down too much,
but it's a situation where you are
making the best of it. Right? Exactly.
And what I found in life,
when you make the best of something
you don't get plagued with,
because let's say the two scenarios,
one, you're making the best of it too.
You're not. So when you're not,
it's going to be burdening.
Burdening you everyday
echoes only moving 10 brick.
That's gonna bother me every day.
It doesn't have to do, by the way,
you're still gonna move
the same amount of bricks.
We're going to get the same amount of
work done, 10 bricks, a hundred bucks,
200 bucks, whatever. But meanwhile,
you're getting tortured all day because
you're that the fact that echoes not
moving as many breaks or he's in
the air conditioned room, whatever,
that's bothering me every single day.
But if you understand that we're
making the best of this situation,
that's not going to bother you. You
know, we're making the best of it, right?
It's the best situation.
Very true, better attitude, you know,
make the best of the sitch.
Next question.
Ego is the enemy.
It can you take that too far?
I can joke about myself
all day and be okay,
but also I don't want coworkers
not to take me seriously.
Is there,
that's actually kind of two questions.
It's talking about ego and they're
talking about joking around, right, right.
Those are, those are two different things.
A little bit like self deprecating.
Yeah.
And so can you,
can you be too humble and put your ego
in so much? Check that it hurts you?
Yes. Actually you can't. Hmm.
You know. Hey, echo, how's
it going? I'm in charge. Um,
I'm really horrible at that Shit. I just
don't know what I'm doing right now.
That's not good. You know, it's like I
said to the, the Marine lieutenant, right.
Am I telling him to go and into
check in and say, Hey, I, you know,
I just don't, I just got here.
Just got out of the basic school.
I don't know anything. Really. Yeah.
Do you want to follow that guy? No,
that's the one I'm talking about suits.
Oh, can you be overly humble? Yes.
Like I said, it's okay to admit
that you don't know everything,
but that doesn't mean
don't be well prepared.
That doesn't mean don't be confident
that you can figure things out.
That doesn't mean you can't
ask good questions. Right.
It doesn't mean that you don't report
in without knowing the nomenclature and
the fundamentals. Right. That's going
to, you know, hey, Jocko just checked in,
but he knows what our mission's been.
He knows what our mission statement is.
He knows how our basic processes,
he already looked at all that.
He knows everyone's name. Yeah,
I'm prepared. I'm prepared.
So that's what you want to be.
That's not saying I have no idea what
I'm doing right now. I just got here. No,
no, that's not what we're talking
about. So don't be overly humble.
Most people,
the reason I talk about the other one of
be humble all the time is because most
people tend towards letting
their ego be inflated.
That's what most people tend towards.
So I tend to talk more about, hey,
keep your ego in check
when you weren't checking.
Because most people that are so
scared of looking bad, they say, well,
I know how to do this.
It never seen it before.
I know how to do that and it never seen
it before. You're going to look stupid.
Hey guys,
I've been put in charge of this.
I know you guys have
been doing it for awhile.
Looking forward to learning from you
and how you execute it and and driving
forward and keeping kicking ass in this
mission. Does anyone get mad at that? No.
That's a lot different than hey guys,
I have no idea what's happening.
That's too much. Yeah. So
don't go there and be humble,
but not, not passive.
Put your ego in check,
but don't turn into a
baby. Work the day. Uh,
the second part of this, this question
about joking around too much and that's,
you know,
that's different from too much ego and
absolutely you can joke around too much.
Now of course.
And we've talked about this,
a good team and a good leader.
They're having fun,
they're having fun with everything that
you're doing. And I always had fun.
I always had fun. I still have
fun all the time. I'm having fun.
But if all you do is
joke around all the time,
but then when it comes time
for the joke to be over,
people won't take you seriously. So
that will be problematic. You know,
I had a rule that was no
joking on the radios. Right?
So if you were on a radio,
you weren't allowed to take make jokes.
No joking on the radio.
And what's cool about that?
Cause you know and tasking a bruiser.
When I was a platoon commander,
when I was assistant to the commander,
we had fallen all the time. We laughed,
we joked, we had a blast with everything
we did. No joking on the radio.
You see what I'm saying? Yeah. That
was a law. No joking on the radio.
And what was good about it
was as I think back to that,
what that translated to was we're not
joking around in the field and that
expanded, look, when we're
briefing, we're not joking around.
It was a very clear distinction.
Of course.
Did people have we did things happen
out in the field sometimes we're like,
oh my God, this is hilarious. Of
course that happened, but the general,
99% of the time, 95% of the time
was, hey, we're in the field.
We're working. We are serious. That's the
priority. Did we have fun in the field?
Yes. Did I laugh in the field? Yes.
But the priority and this
norm was we are going,
we are serious and we're,
that's the priority.
So don't joke so much that you
don't get taken seriously. One time
I was with a senior ranking officer,
a flag officer,
meaning an officer with stars,
and we went to go brief.
I wasn't attached to this unit,
but then when they went to go brief this
unit or we went to go receive a brief
from a unit and in the brief,
in a power point side,
these guys had put a slide in
that was an inappropriate slide.
And it was a crude joke and it was really
funny. I thought it was really funny,
you know, I was like, oh, that's pretty
funny that these guys did that. Y'All did.
I saw the slide. They had it up there
and it was completely inappropriate and,
and, and vulgar. Right.
That's what it was.
They didn't know this general at all.
And he was a very straitlaced guy and
didn't appreciate that kind of humor.
And they, they, they, they
had like the welcome slide.
The next slide that came up was
this inappropriate vulgar slide.
What was it was, it was, it was,
it was, it was inappropriate.
I'll leave it at that.
And,
and you know,
it was like there was a chuckle in the
room and at the same time there was
nothing but silence in the room. You
could feel the discomfort. And, and,
and since like I said,
I thought it was funny and I knew
it wasn't going to go over well.
As soon as I saw us,
Ooh, this is not good.
And the reason I'm telling this big long
story, it's cause I have another rule.
Don't put jokes into your
slides in PowerPoint,
no jokes because you can,
you can articulate the joke cause you can
feel the room out and see what's going
on. You can get it. Get a
taste. You can get a feel for
them if you, if you walk in,
if they would've had a chance, if I could
have said freeze the first slides up.
You, you've met the general
here for for five minutes,
do you want to remove that side?
They'd be like, oh absolutely.
Let's get it out of that. Because they
could see that he was a serious guy and,
and not, you know, one to be that that
wants to be seen. That kind of thing.
It didn't take, wasn't hard.
Who's pretty easy book to read,
but you don't have that
opportunity. There was no, hold on.
We're going to delete this slide. Nope.
There it was. Boom. Welcome. It was the,
it was after the slide of, you know, this
is where we are was the welcome slide.
And I said, Ooh. So it's no joke,
you know, on the radio, no joking.
And your slides keep your slides
clean and, and the, the risk benefit.
You tell a good joke, hey,
that's great. You get, you know,
two credits. If your joke is bad
and considered an appropriate,
it's negative 39 not worth
it. Yeah. It's not worth it.
And again, I'm all
about, you know, you are,
you want to have fun when you're briefing.
You want people to be
entertained and have fun,
but you don't want to have
inappropriate stuff. No. Yeah.
So that's that for both these,
for both these things.
Am I joking too much or am I
being too serious? Am I, you know,
is my ego too big or am
I being too humble? You,
it's a balance. It's a
dichotomy, leadership.
And you've got to find the right spot
in the middle and you've got to check
yourself and you gotta you know,
if your team is joking when they
shouldn't be joking, guess what?
You're leading them the wrong direction.
If your team is somber and
doesn't have any spirit,
you're not having good enough times.
So you gotta find the balance there.
Same thing with ego.
You know,
are people talking with
you and communicating with
you and being open with you
and telling you when they disagree with
things or is no one talking to you.
Cause if that's the case, your ego's so
big that they don't want to talk to you.
So find the dichotomy of leadership to
find the balance between those two. Dang,
that's a good one. If, if
they're, um, if they're not
talking to you, cause you know,
Holland at work, you're talking
with your friends, you know,
then then somebody comes, that
person comes who, you know,
for whatever reason,
you're not necessarily talking about them,
but they come in your car, you got to
stop your conversation, you know? Yeah.
It does like a little indicator,
you know, if you roll up to,
you see people across the room
talking and you're like, hey,
that looks like a cool conversation or
whatever. I'm going to go say hi to Paul,
whatever. And you go and they stopped
talking and they stopped laughing.
They just stopped talking and they
give you like small talk or whatever.
That's an indicator. Yeah,
it's an indicator. Uh,
could be actually either one of those too.
If people are having a good time and
you walk in and they stop laughing,
all of a sudden you say,
okay.
And if you walk in and they're having
a conversation that they don't,
they just don't want to talk to you.
They're probably,
they probably don't like your big
ego that's slapping them in the face.
Okay. Put your ego in check. Yup.
We've got time for one more.
One more.
Jocko.
Do you ever get worn down by everything
you're trying to do and the things going
wrong and things not working and having
to work so hard only to come up short.
What do you do then?
Of course
meet. Of course. Of
course. I get worn down.
Of course I get frustrated with stuff.
Of course.
Things don't always go my way.
Then of course I come up short sometimes
of course.
But what do I do?
Those things happen.
Yeah,
I keep going.
It's,
it's really that simple.
I put one foot in front of the other.
I move forward another
inch on another centimeter.
Aye.
Right.
One more sentence.
I I in place one board brick on the wall.
I got through one more workout.
I step out onto the mat one more time
because
because worn down
isn't beaten
and frustration is not going to kill me
and the things that don't go my way,
they just turn into targets that
I'm going to attack hoarder.
And when I do come up short,
it's okay cause I just learned one more
thing that's going to get me over the
top.
So
at those moments,
those low points,
those times when it seems right,
that defeat
is starting to get the upper hand.
You don't need some grand plan
and you don't need a pep talk
and you don't need a miracle.
You just need to keep going,
keep going,
just keep going and don't stop
regardless of what you are hit with.
Because if you don't stop yourself,
okay,
the nothing else can
and nothing else will.
And I think that's all
I've got for tonight.
So Echo,
why don't you go ahead and talk about how
we can support this podcast if we want
to, if we want to, and support
yourself if we want to,
which we do by the way. So we talk
about on it, on it supplements,
physical and mental,
by
the way. So I think, uh, you know, I,
I know if we failed to mention this or
we just been mentioning it a little bit
less, which is Alpha brain
we haven't talked about.
I feel like we haven't talked about
Alpha brain and that much recently.
Been taking it by the way, but not
talking about it. Um, this is good. Okay.
So it's a new shoe. They call it a
nootropic or nootropic nootropics.
I'm like that helps your brain
nutrients to your brain. Boom. Directly.
So two forms.
The instant it's like powder,
you mix it up with your
Gatorade or whatever, whatever.
No, you don't need that.
It doesn't, you can mix it on its own,
right, right. There's two flavors.
There's peach and then there's natural
spice and they get the two flavors tastes
exactly like what they sound,
what they're named.
Peaches tastes like peach and natural
spice. All natural spice kick too.
But it's also,
it's got a little peach but it's got
a little natural spices was like Dang,
I didn't know those two flavors.
Yeah I have both. What is this one?
This one is all this one is natural
spice. Central Spice. Yeah. Dagit boom.
But they have, they, they,
they taste sweet. Right?
So you don't need to mix it with Gatorade
and you shouldn't be having Gatorade
anyways cause it's just a bunch
of sugar in water even at a punch.
But we'll say some, some
electrolytes in it. Nonetheless,
mix it with whatever you want, man.
Um, or just poured it into your body.
It's powder. That's the thing compared
to the capsules. Yup. Whatever you like,
you know,
don't have the powder one is called
instant so it goes to your brain quick,
quicker. That's just an assumption
nonetheless here. This is what it does,
which is cool.
So you know how like you know how you're
talking to somebody and you blank out
on some something like somebody whose
name no, whatever you're doing today.
Today because you gave me a word. Yeah. I
don't think that's tackled before. Wait.
Oh, before we were recording while we
were recording live acquaintance. Yes.
Acquaintance. I didn't have
enough Alpha brain. No,
that was before we were recording
anything. No. All right. Well there it is.
Either way. That's what it does. Do
you need more Alpha brain now? No,
I think you do.
I think I'm right cause I took two of
these and I think that that I'm correct
nonetheless.
Doesn't even matter.
Because what it does is it
makes you do that like whale,
actually you don't even do it. And I'm,
I don't, I mean maybe that's a deficient,
something about some kind of
deficiency when that happens. You know,
when they call them brain farts,
I'm having a brain fart. You know,
you don't get brands in cosmetics.
It's like Gasx for your brain essentially.
You know how like Gasx you know
what that does, right? So you don't,
you don't do that. You don't have to think
of words anymore. They just calm. Boom.
For Real. Now I don't want, I kind
of don't want to bring this up,
but I will anyways because I don't
want to give people bias. What I don't,
you can tell him about
cognitive bias services,
but if you heard people like your
brother jade who says when he takes Alpha
brain, his dreams get all crazy.
Yeah. So that's another thing that I,
and I've, I've seen, I've talked to other
people that, that get more vivid dreams,
right? With the Alpha Brady. Yeah.
So that's another thing just to be aware
of now just I want, I don't want to,
what kind of cognitive biases that,
that's not availability bias because I
said it and now you're waiting for it.
And so now you have a favorite
dream you think is the Alpha brain.
That's our goal. Right? Right. That's like
that's a placebo effect. Yeah, I guess.
But you're attributing it to something.
You're attributing it to Alpha brain all.
Yeah. Huh. So anyways, that is a bias.
You may notice that your
dreams become more vivid.
I don't notice it,
but I've heard some people say it.
I think I heard Joe Rogan talking about,
I heard a Monday.
And jade is one of those.
Jay Definitely,
he said it before I even
heard anyone else say.
He's like all that's like a good thing.
He didn't, it wasn't a complaint too.
That's the thing. Lucid dreaming,
see change. But yeah, I liked it.
I don't have lucid dreams.
I have savage nightmares is what I
have and I wake up in a pool of sweat.
It's just a get some, an Alpha
brain fueled. Savage nightmare.
Don't need that.
We're not going to visit down.
Hopefully that doesn't happen to you,
but the benefit that I am going to claim
and this and it's proven to, by the way,
in a double blind placebo test official
off of rain helps with your like recall,
like your memory and all that stuff,
which that's essentially what
it is when you think about it,
when you get a little that one
word bone that recap on boom, boom.
It's just firing. That's
how often brain, so yeah,
if you're about to do something where
you got to think and talk a lot,
which is everything good on that Alpha
bring, then you'd be glad you did.
I took what I used to do a lot,
so before,
before I knew how to switch
to manual mode. Regardless,
I would take a pre workout and Alpha brain
and it helped. Whose money? Yeah.
I actually got one of my better
workouts on that little formula,
so I just kept doing it. But you know how
you'd do something over and over again,
whether the physiologically or otherwise,
you just, you tend to lose that. Yeah.
It's like if you take caffeine
all the time. Yes. Yeah.
In a way it's the same thing. I say
Alpha brain is like take it all the time.
Right? You get on the regular.
Yeah, it'd be in the blood. Yeah.
So mine more left that
to do with like the,
the direct effect of Alpha brain and my
memory and recall it was more about the
kind of workout I got, you know, placebo,
by the way. Maybe, maybe not though.
That's the thing. Or maybe I was just
thinking of more cool stuff, you know,
so it was more enjoyable work out.
Could have been that perhaps. Maybe not.
Nonetheless, we can stick to
the evidence and the proof.
You'll recall stuff better.
Remember,
memorize things better. It's
good all day, every day.
I'm also like got that strong bone
member a few weeks back I'll say does a
strong you're, yeah, the facts.
Strontium. It's one of those things.
Here's the thing too. You read the
thing, so calcium is, that's the,
that's the flagship element,
mineral element, whatever.
Calcium, that's the one that gets all
the credit for your bones. It's like,
you know the strontium is like the
stepchild is like as far as recognition,
but strontium is super
important and you lose that.
You know when you get old and whatever.
But that's what,
that's a strong bone is
you think strontium? Yeah.
You think it's strong bone
makes your bones strong,
which I think that's on purpose too.
It's like a little play on words.
You think so? I think so. I'll
he's smart like 10 anyway,
take that strong will I? I did it because
as you know, I had a bicep surgery,
tend to know my bicep ripped off my bone.
So if I'm still lifting,
I still do curls, whatever I said it,
I don't need that thing ripping off.
I don't need tendinitis. I don't
need problems. I don't need issues.
I've got on that strong bone. Also, I take
Krill oil. Jocko. Do you take Krill oil?
Affirmative? I think you've been
taking Krill oil longer than I haven't.
And when I say I think it
means I know long crime,
even though I've been hearing great
things about Krill oil from day one.
So anyway, on the Krill oil that helps
with joints. It gives you this feeling.
I said this before,
I will say it again.
It gives you this feeling
where then this physically,
it's not emotionally feelings
or emotional, just Fyi.
No feeling doe. If I flick your finger,
you're going to feel that true. So this,
yeah, no, no. All good.
All good. You feel like,
like if you're sitting down for a
long time and then you stand up. Yeah,
we'll talk about it,
but when I stand,
I stand up. Well, you're on Krill oil, so
this applies to you too. When we stand up,
if Greg train was here like
we were like a few weeks ago,
if great train was right,
he wasn't on the Krill oil.
We all stand up after the same
amount of time, two hours ish.
He will be compelled to be
like, ah, make that sound crazy.
But he'll be compelled to make that sound.
Whether it makes it or not,
he's going to feel like making
it meet. I won't you. You won't.
Krill oil makes your joints young again,
for lack of better term. Anyway. It helps
though. Yes, but in all seriousness,
if you are like lifting weights,
going hard, take her along. Yeah,
take the Krill oil.
It'll,
I mean where would want to do that on
[inaudible] dot com if you want 10% off,
you go on [inaudible] dot com slash
Jocko it's the best Krill oil too.
That's the thing. You can get lane
krill oil anywhere. Maybe not anywhere,
but in other places will say, but the
real deal, that good stuff is on it.
You don't want to get lame
Krill oil from name Krill. Yeah,
the hardcore grill. It's true. Do you
know how like um, like Asai Berries,
you know like you know,
you,
you can get junk os I eat like the
reject us I and paid like cheaper.
Actually this Krill oil is actually super
good price anyway and you get 10% off
from [inaudible] dot com slash
chocolate that's a 10% offer.
Nonetheless, back to the,
let's see berries, you can get
the junk cane in, treaties,
junk Asai Berries and then taste good.
Asai berries brought the differences.
Like you can tell the difference big time.
It's like night and day.
Same thing with the Krill oil. Take
the good on, man. Forget the lame one.
That's just my opinion anyway. Good.
Another good way to support podcasts.
Amazon. Click through all you do before
you do any of your Amazon shopping,
click through the website
Jockos podcast.com
I got a little hint from
somebody in the field that said,
hey,
when you tell people to do Amazon,
click through.
What you should tell them is to tell
their significant other to click through.
Hmm. For instance, in my case, my wife
buys more things on Amazon than I do.
I'm in the game.
I'm supporting the podcast,
but what if my wife doesn't know
about the click through, right.
She needs to get in the game.
Yeah. Double support right there.
Don't just you do it. Get your
family, get your wife, get your,
your husband. Right. They're not in the
game. Get them in the game. Yeah. Huh.
That's a lot of,
a lot of times the the other spouse
is buying the stuff on Amazon. Yeah,
and they don't know how to support.
Right.
They don't know about that website or
they're just less compelled or they forgot
and you don't really, technically you
don't know if they forgot or not. You know
if you're clever,
heard this from Sam Harris.
I knew this already. I'm be honest,
but I heard it. To reinforce it,
where some people they will click
through and before they do shopping,
they get that you little URL. Boom. Save
it to favorites. Save it two to Bodie.
Call it bookmarks, both and then
top. So boom, it's there. It's a,
it's in the front of your head now.
It's a good way to support small action
takes what? Three seconds if that,
if that. Yeah, and huge support.
It's like huge reinforcements
enforcements. Actually.
That's how strong support it
is. Small action. Big Reaction.
Yup. Like sodium when you throw it in
water. Anyway, subscribe to the podcast.
If you want. Itunes, Cornell,
deep shelf. Could you play?
That's the best example you can think of.
Really.
You want me to say anything else, man?
He said it. We're good over here. Yeah.
I can't think of a better one.
Subscribe.
If you want iTunes, stitcher,
Google, play, all these podcasting,
providing platforms and you know,
you'll get on the list.
You know, you click on my podcast, boom,
automatic. It'll be, it'll be there,
the new one updated every week.
So you can just click play.
You don't got to do the search anymore.
You know when you do that,
you go on there and you, hey, let me see
this podcast. You got to search podcasts.
You got to type it in on your phone.
It's actually not that big of a deal,
but it'd be even less of a big deal.
If you subscribe,
you just click on my podcast,
boom, updated automatically there.
So, so, uh, subscribe to the
podcast. That's a good way
to support leave a review.
If you're in the mood chocolates, said
something extra dope. You're like, hey,
I liked that. Leave Review. Feel
free like Nate got, I don't want,
what do you call that? Muzzle? Like what
you put on the dogs to stop them. Yeah.
We're not trying to muzzle anybody.
I was thinking about a muzzle
over here for something to see,
and it's good that you
exercise a no muzzle policy.
And I think that policy should extend
to anyone who's listening and want to
support this podcast.
That's what I think.
And apparently that's what you think
too. And I liked that obviously. Yeah.
So subscribe. Also subscribe to Youtube.
Yeah, we have a youtube channel.
I know I say it every week.
I'm gonna say it again.
I'll say it this week we
have a youtube channel.
Video version of this podcast is on the
youtube channel, which is cool. Obvious,
right? But with strong recommendations
from Jocko, from others
online,
they recommended that you cut out
little excerpts, put them on Youtube,
even make a playlist, which I did
and did it. We did all of that stuff.
So there's excerpts on there. If you
want to listen to three minutes of junk.
Old opinion on what Jim,
what home gym, what?
What equipment makes a good home gym.
You want to listen to that? Boom.
It's available right there. How
should I approach college? Boom.
Jock advice right there. So these
exit, I think they're actually,
the more I kind of look at them and
stuff I think is a valuable situation.
Can you can share him easy and people
are way more likely to listen to little
excerpts in the whole thing if you're
trying to get one element of the podcast.
So yeah, youtube subscribe to that. Good
way to support. Good way to support. Also,
Jack was a store called Jocko store.
If,
okay,
you want to wear tee shirts and represent,
we've got some new ones.
We've got a new one on there. Um, but
regardless of the new ones, old ones,
whichever,
just go in there,
see if you like one get one good
way to support and boom, tee shirt.
Also hoodies,
rash guards,
which you're not my words, other
people's words, they're pretty dope.
So you know,
if you're into activity that you like
range of motion and you want to represent
and you want to support,
get a rash guard that those are good.
I did them for Jujitsu originally. But
Pam, if, yeah, if you, if you serve,
if you do crossfit,
metcons, whatnot, cycling,
run marathons.
I'm listing all the things that people
send me pictures of them doing in their
rash guard. So that's why I'm
going down this list. Other stuff,
if you do all that perfect for that too.
Very perfect.
Can something be very perfect? It's
either perfect or not, right? Yup. Yeah.
Either way. This is women's stuff
on there. Uh, some patches, velcro
regulation size and color,
um, hoodies as well. Also,
maybe the mugs are on there,
maybe not. Nonetheless.
I'll talk more about the travel
mugs later next time. Also
go Jocko, store.com. I think
I said that, but if you know,
there it is a reminder Jocko
starr.com is the website. That's okay.
Good way to support and support yourself.
Psychological warfare.
What psychological warfare is, I know
you said it before. I'll say it again.
Psychological warfare is an album
with tracks, not music tracks.
Jocko tracks.
And if you are,
you know, I'm starting to not
like the word self improvement.
I already don't like that word. Right?
Yeah. It kind of like starting to, yeah.
You know, it's kind of like
it. Yeah. And I'm to the point,
I'm like midway through not liking it.
You know, the phases is like doom, boom.
You hear something, you're like, okay,
that's cool and acceptable mid phases.
Like that's cool, but I don't
like how it sounds when I say it.
And then the last phase is you don't,
you just don't want to hear it. I mean,
you made phase so, but I'm
going to use it, you know,
for just for the greater good.
If you're going to self improvement path.
Journey journey is another one
of those words that you know,
you're waking up early,
you're doing workouts now consistently.
You're consistently,
consistently eating good.
What about studying and reading and
getting smarter too. Yeah, those studying,
reading,
um,
writing even anything creative,
you know, man, when you,
and that's the thing that jams people up
when they're like, hey, I should do this.
I should write my ebook, or I should, I
should do a journal every day or whatever,
you know, and they'll do it one day
and then they just won't do it anymore.
You know? That's the thing.
So anyway, you've been,
regardless of what you're doing,
these tracks,
psychological part,
these tracks will help you
through this at times of weakness.
If you're trying to get up in
the morning and it's that day,
you know you had a long night and a
hard workout that morning that you're
looking forward to or not looking forward
to and you're like, you know what,
I'm going to just going to snooze
or I'm going to skip the workout.
You listen to a certain one or
two or three of these tracks.
It's Jacqueline who gets you through
that moment of weakness and you will work
out.
You will wake up early,
100% probability with very few,
if any exceptions.
Also on Amazon while
you're clicking through,
you can get some Jocko white tea,
which has some pretty good effects.
I just pulled a couple of reviews out.
This one here says drinking Jockos white
tea has had the following effects on my
life getting after it up.
55% extreme ownership up 92% mm hmm.
And also by the way,
cruising all day up 108%
so that's important.
Also dead lift when from three 25 to
five 55 20 pull ups instead of sets of
solid.
That's good improvement.
I don't think anyone would instead
of instead of five, five yeah,
it's good.
There's another person that drank the
tea and I thought that this was important
because it could happen to other people.
Okay.
So this person bought some Jocko white
tea for myself and my next workout was so
aggressive.
I got a strongly worded letter
from the UN to cease hostilities.
So I don't, I don't like seeing
UN involvement on our workouts,
but if you're not careful it might happen.
And also there's another person I
hadn't talked about front squatting,
but you know,
one person that has been drinking Jocko
white tea is now front squatting about
2000 pounds. Again, just Jocko
white tea, no big deal. Uh,
to double, triple, quadruple.
[inaudible]. Ultimate tested.
Flawless.
Yeah.
Jocko white tea man tastes good
and it is good also right now,
the way of the warrior kid, it's
out. We've been waiting for it.
I've been waiting for it.
Boom. Thanks everyone for
picking it up. Getting a copy.
If you haven't gotten it
yet, get it. You know what,
you probably don't.
You probably wonder if you need it.
Maybe you think you don't need it.
So then Lexar little excerpt for you.
Now this is young mark.
He couldn't do any pull ups.
You couldn't do any pull ups. He's in
fifth grade, couldn't do any followups.
Sure get made fun of.
People are laughing at him because
he can't do any pull ups. His uncle,
uncle Jake, he stays with them for the
summer. Uncle Jake's and the seal teams,
Uncle Jake gets them
on the workout program.
What you and I are commonly referred to
as the program gets him on the program
and it's been a few weeks now and
uncle Jake realizes that mark,
he's been doing negatives and he's been
doing assisted pull ups and he's been
doing the pyramids, but just to hanging
on the bar, doing all those things,
getting ready and uncle Jake realized
now he's ready to do his first pull up.
So he says to him, you know,
okay, you're going to get on.
You can do your first pull up today
and we'll go to the back to the
book. There you go. He said,
giddy up.
Get on the bar
and here's young mark. I was filled with
fear every time I had tried in the past,
no matter how hard I pulled,
I could never get my chin over the bar.
Now with uncle Jake standing right here
after all the work is done with me,
I just didn't think I'd be able to do it.
I stood there looking up at the
bar. Well, what are you waiting for?
Said Uncle Jake.
I slowly stepped up on the box
and reached up for the bar.
The bar was cool in my hands and I
noticed something that I hadn't thought
about. My grip in the, my grip always felt
like it was going to slip off the bar.
My grip felt different.
Now it felt strong.
I concentrated and then after taking a
big breath I pulled and I went up and up
and up and soon my chin cleared
the top of the bar. Yes,
I had done it. I let myself down
solely and dropped off the bar.
I looked at my uncle, he had a big
smile on his face, a big smile.
He was happy and I was even happier.
It felt so good.
I looked at Uncle Jake and yelled Ya.
As I curled both my fist towards my
shoulder like I'd seen weightlifters do in
magazines and I could actually tell for
the first time in my life I was starting
to get some muscles. Nothing huge, but
they were certainly their muscle man.
Mark,
I shouted as proud as I could be.
Then I saw uncle Jake smiled disappear.
Hold on.
Their muscle man said Uncle Jake.
I didn't know what was wrong,
but something was,
I think it's a bit early
for a celebration early.
I just did the first pull up of my life.
I think it's the perfect time for
a celebration. I told Uncle Jake,
that's a problem. Uncle Jake said a
problem. Why is it pull up a problem?
Not the pull up mark. The celebration.
It is way too early for celebrating,
but I just did my first pull up ever.
But your goal isn't one pull up.
Your goal is 10 pull ups.
You did one.
Sure you have a reason to be happy.
One pull up is better than zero,
but it's a long way from 10
no matter what you're doing in life,
you can't take your eyes off the long
term goal, especially to celebrate.
You can assess,
you can try and figure out some lessons
learned from what you did right and what
you did wrong. You can even do a little
celebrating for the small victories,
but don't go overboard.
You need to keep your head in the game.
So come over here,
give me a high five and they get back
over there and start doing more work on
the pullup bar.
This is only the beginning.
I walked over to uncle Jake who
brought his hand up in the air.
I slapped it hard and he said,
solid work.
Now get back over there and get after it.
Yes sir.
I told him
just a little,
another little lesson from Uncle Jake.
You can't get cocky when you
make the little achievement.
You've got to keep your eye on the ball.
So that's it.
Check out that book, order it, weigh
the warrior kid. It's a kid's book.
That's what they're telling me.
I think we all learned a little something
from it. I know I learned from writing.
It can also pre a border,
a book called discipline
equals freedom field manual
and it's we're dialing in right now.
It's going to come out October
17th it isn't a workout book.
It isn't a philosophy book.
It isn't a photography book.
It isn't a diet book.
Okay.
It's got all those things in there,
but how do you categorize it?
Where are you going to put, where are
you gonna put it in the bookstore?
Where's it going to be?
Where's it going to be on Amazon?
You know where it's going to be,
where it's going to be in the get
after it category and you know what?
It's going to be the only book in
there so you can order that one.
You can also order extreme ownership.
Of course,
if you want to lead in when you can
get that book for you and your team.
If you need some leadership training live,
you can contact our company. Ashland,
Ashland phone is a leadership and
management consulting business.
We teach your company to lead with the
same principles of leadership that we
learned in combat. So if you want
to get us in the game with you,
email info@ashkelonfront.com
yeah,
we have the monster zero zero two
coming up at the Marriott Grand Marquis,
May 4th and fifth
leadership strategy tactics. If you don't
make that one, guess what? That's okay.
Texas July 13th and 14th at the
Omni Barton creek resort and spa.
I'm gonna tell you right up,
straight up.
Don't come for the spa and
not going to see the spot.
If you can't make the one in Texas,
San Diego,
September 14th and 15th
follow on operation.
We've been there once we're coming back
again. Come get your leadership game on.
Improve yourself as a
leader and as a person.
We'll see you at one of those monsters.
Look forward to it when
we're not at the monsters.
We can be found on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and we go on to be here.
Laxing on that phase,
that Phase II book.
What Echo is at echocharles
and I am at Jocko Willink.
And thanks everybody for listening and
for supporting and for asking these
questions and for helping us do what we
do to the military personnel overseas.
All of you,
our deepest thanks and appreciation
for your service and sacrifice.
Stay safe.
The best way to stay safe is to stay
aggressive to the police firefighters,
EMT, first responders.
Thanks for staying sharp,
training hard and standing.
Watch for us here at home
and to everybody listening,
life isn't easy
and it's not supposed to be.
Sure.
There's victories and there's triumphs,
but there's also losses and setbacks.
But those losses and setbacks
only win if you let them.
So don't let them,
don't let them win no matter what happens.
Keep going,
keep getting after it.
So until next time, this
is echo and Jocko. Oh
out.